All right,
the big day is here.
We're finally doing the Rubin report fan
show.
In case you missed it a couple of weeks
back,
I had asked you guys to let me know why
I should interview you and I got to tell
you guys,
you did not disappoint me.
We got almost 1200 responses within a
week and ended up selecting 20 of you
instead of the original five that we had
intended.
We're gonna release these over the
course of a couple of weeks,
each video with a few eight to 10 minute
interviews.
Many of you guys wrote incredible essays
on what's going on in your life and in
your corner of the world.
I promise you that we read every single
entry.
It took us a long time and it was
incredibly difficult to make the
decision of who to choose.
We did our best to pick an eclectic mix
of people from all over the world.
On a personal note,
I just want to say how truly,
truly honored and humbled I am by your
submissions.
The fact that you guys watched this
show,
share it with friends and family and are
engaging in the battle of ideas
yourself,
really makes putting myself out there
worthwhile.
I'm honored really to have such an
incredible fan base that not only is
connecting with me but with each other
as well.
Clearly you guys all recognize that
we're in this together and that talking
about the important issues honestly,
is the only way to move forward as part
of the human race.
All right.
Then the first ever Rubin report fan
show is here.
Let's roll.
All right.
I'm on with Sophie in London.
Sophie,
has it gone?
I'm amazing.
Thank you so much for having me tonight,
Dave.
Yeah,
my pleasure.
All right,
so,
uh,
I saw on twitter.
You're very excited to talk to me.
I have a whole list of things that you
had written in originally about,
but I sensed that more than anything
else you want to talk about feminism as
am I right?
Yeah.
My favorite topic.
It's delicious.
Delicious.
All right,
well let's,
let's dive right in.
What are your feelings about feminism in
2016?
Well,
the problem is feminism to 2016 isn't
the feminism that once was,
I think,
I think we know from Milo Yiannopoulos
and Christina Hoff sommers who promoted
it amazingly well.
This idea that modern feminism has
become a kin to martin heating has,
it,
has.
Um,
and I myself having been brought up in a
family of mostly females with my dad,
of course,
bless his heart.
I know the value of being a strong
independent woman,
as Cliche as it sounds.
And that doesn't involve safe spaces.
That doesn't involve shying away from
debate.
You know,
what it involves,
it involves being equal to a man.
It involves working to be equal.
So you know,
everything about this whole safe space
concept is extremely dangerous because
these people,
these students,
universities like myself,
they will be subject to mollycoddling to
being told they have victims all the
time.
And I imagine you're being constantly
told her a victim.
What is that going to change your
mentality that extremely damaging.
And that is what might've modernists,
feminism is doing to women all the time.
And it's depressing because we all meant
to be for gender equality.
So why are we telling these women,
why are we telling females everywhere
that you can't do this,
that this mystical force,
the patriarchy is supposedly oppression
pressing us.
And now I say this,
obviously a patriarchy is a serious
issue in countries such as Middle East
and India for instance,
in the West,
you know,
I can walk out my house without a male
mind and it's.
And it's fine.
You know,
I don't have this,
I don't have this oppression or May.
Yeah.
So you're telling me you're safe when
you walk out of your house in London,
you can make it to the store without a
man and you can do that on your own.
You know what I mean?
Sometimes I do get a bit of a panic
attack coming up because I feel,
I feel like sometimes a wolf football's
gonna come at me and then I'm going to
be triggered and then it's just going to
be horrific.
But I,
you know,
I just manage it.
I just manage it,
Dave.
And this.
The sad thing is is that this is
extremely patronizing to women and you
know what?
We're for real quality.
Why are we shying away?
This takes is it takes three steps
backwards.
This is ridiculous.
It is ridiculous and the thing is with
modern day feminist feminism,
like I said,
it doesn't support men's needs as well.
If we want gender rights,
gender equality,
we have to consider things that they
aren't addressing now from what I
previously stated,
the patriarchy.
Now feminist like to consider it an
oppressive force on females and they
like to paint it on western females as
well,
not just those that are generally
oppressed.
No,
I would say the Patriarchy is doing a
bloody bad job at benefiting the
oppresses.
If we look at the end endemic of male
suicides,
for instance,
if we look at the rates of male to
female ratios are going to university,
especially in the UK.
It's atrocious and I can't help but feel
that these modern day feminist fighting
battles out already won in the,
in the,
in the West,
you know,
you know what a pet newspaper here in
the UK,
the Guardian,
I'm sure you are a big fan of these and
those,
those lovely articles,
a little aggressive for me,
but every now and again there's
something.
Okay,
exactly.
There's always like a.
I'm a fairly good discussion on an.
It's like a diamond in the rough,
but the most part has become sort of
click bait.
Guess what we're going to appropriate
today.
What sexist today?
How can I be a victim today?
And it's so disempowering.
You know,
I want to read articles about women
making it in the world,
which we do,
which we do because we are equal to men
and we should be so proud of it.
So why are we shying away from that?
Why are we teaching these students that,
you know,
men are horrible creatures,
which is something that I detest because
we are equal and when I say equal,
we are not the same because we all
biologically different.
And again,
we should be so proud of that.
We should be proud that we fill each
other's differences.
We compliment each other.
It's a wonderful thing.
Yeah.
All right,
so we got to pause there because you're
giving me a lot.
I love it.
And you know,
know I'm on board most of these ideas.
And you know what,
I promise you,
I'm going to send this to Christina
directly so she can,
she can listen.
Oh lovely.
But,
uh,
so when you talk about these ideas,
it's very obvious to me.
You're not just telling me this,
this is something you talk about in
your,
in your life as well.
When you talk about this either at
university or with your friends.
Um,
are you,
Shawn,
have you been fighting with people?
What's going on?
I've been told to check my privilege
because I'm apparently I'm not oppressed
enough.
I'm not oppressed enough as a woman.
I'm,
you know,
and apparently there are other women out
there in the West that has suffering
from the patriarchy.
I am yet to be aware of.
I think they should also talk to the
young working class x coal miner in
Yorkshire who is currently suffering and
can barely afford a council flat tax,
you know,
so these are just slight discrepancy in
that little chick and they don't see
this and I can totally,
I can totally empathize with what
they're trying to do that they're trying
to find some good.
They're trying to do something.
I can see the intentions,
but good intentions don't always mean
good results,
you know?
Hell is paved with good intentions.
Exactly.
And like you say,
I do get one a shot and I don't want to
be victimizing myself.
You,
I'm so triggered by talking about it.
That was good to move there.
You could have went that route but I got
out was good.
But in a sense there was a wall.
I will give them videos and say
Christina's talks or you know,
I'll,
I'll link them.
I don't link them to Milo yet.
I mean I adore him,
but I feel like they won't get him quite
yet.
Baby steps,
you know?
Sure.
I'm all linkedin.
Say Peer reviewed studies suggesting
perhaps like,
you know,
um,
the pay wage gap has nothing to do with
the mystical patriarchy but is nearly to
do with job preferences as one of the
factors.
And they will just dismiss it as saying,
oh,
it's just a one off case,
but how many one off cases can you use
as an excuse for that?
It's,
it's,
you know,
Straw Manning,
so to say the least.
Um,
and they're trying to fight a battle
which has already been won as many as
Christina has already said many,
many times.
Yeah.
So do you think that goes to the,
you know,
the feelings over facts,
idea that seems to be what comes out of
unfortunately,
a lot of the left these days.
It is sad and it's sad because as much
as we used the aggressive black men
trope,
so to speak.
And it's very true.
It's very true.
I,
I trying not to think that it's most the
left because you know,
I'm very much a liberal and ideas.
I believe I believe in equality.
I believe in gay marriage.
I believe all of that and I believe in
freedom of expression,
I believe in exchange of ideas and I
truly believe with freedom,
with free exchange of ideas.
You can,
you can,
you can empathize with people,
you can see why people think the way
they think and there's,
there's this hatred,
there's this tension because you're able
to understand one another,
which is ultimately an amazing thing to
do in such a globalized world.
And it's hard to do that when you just
focus solely on emotion,
not logic and rationality,
because then you can misinterpret
something.
You can say it's racist.
You can say it's bigoted.
When it's perfectly innocent statement.
It's probably a statistic that is
suddenly magically turned out to be
racist.
Man,
you are
preaching you my logic or something.
I just mangled that one.
I think you could be my new cohost.
Uh,
I want,
I want to shift to one more with you.
Um,
so you mentioned in your submission that
there is a form of atheism,
also a that you don't like.
And now I've had a lot of atheists on
here.
I'm generally,
I'm pro atheist and I'm pro logic and
reason and all that stuff,
but you think that there is that some of
the movements so to speak has taken a
turn that you don't like.
Can you tell me about that?
So of course I'm an atheist myself.
Huge fan of the secular movement.
I think we're very,
very fortunate to be living,
you know,
mostly secular world with exceptions and
I'm glad we are doing a lot of work
towards fixing that.
How about do you think there is a
sinister smugness and the atheist
movement and I do think it's connected
to some,
some of the fallout because um,
it's very interesting how some of these
people swope Sarah religion for their
own ideology.
Ideology based on the Patriarchy or
based on imaginary things.
And it's very religion like so in an,
in an,
in an essence suddenly swapping
religion.
And I'm not anti religion.
I might be atheist,
but I'm not anti religion at all.
I think there's a lot to be said for
some of the cultural things and the
Anglican Church,
the kingdom has given us culture.
It's given us odd.
It's given us an explosion of things we
can't deny.
Totally.
Exactly.
And so one must be careful when
criticizing belief,
which is totally fine and not the
believer and the benefits of what that
belief has given us.
Um,
but I do also think that some of these
people go get a very Marxist route,
so they do believe that religion is the
opiate of the people say and they
completely,
um,
exchange logic and reason for their own
ideology.
So it's not like they're,
and I'm an atheist because an atheist
because they've discovered science or
they've,
you know,
read more Dawkins,
they become an atheist sort of as a
result of the ideology through the
Cultural Marxism that is being
perpetuated a lot of the academia
nowadays.
That's how I'm,
that's why I'm worried about that route.
But for the most part,
you know,
I'm,
I'm perfectly,
perfectly joyous park at a secular
movement.
So that's,
that's fine with me.
Yeah.
All right,
well listen,
this went by super fast.
Clearly we couldn't,
we could have talked a lot more.
I'm curious what,
what do you want to do with your life?
Because obviously you have a lot to say
and I do get that voice out there
that's very kind of you.
Um,
I have a lot of it.
I want to start my own business.
I'm quite ambitious actually and I'm
just finishing up my final year
university so I'll be free from the
shackles soon enough,
but I'm going to have a think about one
going to do.
Actually I'm gonna have to think that
because this is actually,
this has been a pleasure actually.
Thank you so much for having me on the
show.
All right.
I'm on with John from Turkey that John,
it's spelled c a n,
but as I know that the C in Turkey is a
J.
is that,
is that all I need to know about your
alphabet?
There's a couple of other things I could
probably know,
right?
Uh,
pretty much easy.
Yeah.
All right.
Well we have a lot to talk about because
we've talked a bit about Turkey on the
show and you sent us a great email with
explaining some of your
frustrations with Turkey.
Some of the good things with hurricane.
We're hearing a lot about Turkey in the
news right now for a series of reasons.
Uh,
so I'm gonna start it there.
Give me just the general state of things
in Turkey right now.
Well,
I'm a little tall,
but I can set it up.
Was relatively easy then living in the
region,
but there are still tons on human rights
violation,
pressure on free,
stress free and we also have a massive
refugee crisis and is create sacred
problems,
economical and social problems.
And also we have a really polarized
country like the,
there are many different social and
cultural groups that have different
lifestyles and values and expectations
from the line.
And finally we have within our sites,
we have a internal conflict for done a
lot on how to use the cards and terms
and it blurs the line between the
Islamic center,
the center line lies,
and some second Turks stand together
against the careless.
So I,
I assume you.
Are you totally secular or are you an
atheist?
Are you religious?
Are you Muslim?
Some combination thereof.
No,
I made this and I'm,
I'm,
I'm totally values.
Yeah,
that's it.
Can you be openly atheist,
openly secular there because it sounds
like the prime minister has sort of been
cracking down on or he's making the
country more Islamist in a sense.
Why did he tried his best and he has a
great support.
His name bidding every single election
that he was getting into,
he had been getting into for 14 years.
He has half the every time.
And also we had another becomes a
nationalist party and upon on like,
well,
uh,
you know,
say that we have roughly been pulled off
the population that are sexually and so
secular values that have second
lifestyles sad that Turkey is 99 percent
nine Muslim and that kind of stuff.
But I think it's less than this and it's
a monster.
A atheist community is getting bigger
and bigger and bigger every day and
people are understanding that secular
values are really important for us.
Yeah.
So that's really interesting because,
you know,
we hear from people in the West all the
time,
they always use Turkey as the example of
sort of like,
you know,
a good Muslim country,
because you're okay,
you can do this,
you have no fear about being on this
show,
right?
You can do this and you're not.
I mean I know that Irwin is cracking
down on the press,
but.
Oh,
do you?
Yeah,
I do.
I can't find it if it's a okay to say
it,
but I don't know,
like sometimes I feel like if I need
some certain stuff I,
my job a success,
some stupid things can go badly and that
kind of stuff.
So,
uh,
once it entered the same time I want to,
I want to speak out,
I want to be open and I went on to share
my ideas and values and I will not
Stanford.
And this family's for my country and for
the entire university and especially.
Well,
I love that.
That's exactly why I do the show.
So let's talk a little bit about the
immigration situation because obviously
you guys,
you share a border with Syria,
it sounds like at some level a lot of
the European fighters for Isis come
through Turkey to get there.
Then you guys get the refugees.
Then as you said you,
there's also this issue with the Kurds
who are sort of caught in the middle and
being fought on by,
by both Isis and Turkey.
So what's the general situation as far
as like integrating the immigrants?
Are they staying in Turkey?
Are they just using Turkey to go to the
rest of the Europe?
What's going on?
Well,
no integration because millions of
people keep coming to Turkey and you
cannot shut down to boulder.
You cannot just say that you are not
welcoming you.
So we have to accept that.
But then coming by millions and like
data was three and there's a lot of ice
I started seeing in different cities and
are totally like beggars on the streets,
like people living almost three years in
refugee camps.
And also,
uh,
I'm going to say that like people say to
you about Turkey is a really big
company.
For example,
Syria border is roughly thousand
kilometer make from me.
So,
uh,
I don't see that.
I don't feel that effect of ics.
And then kind of Baobab.
Sydney is in the,
on the border suffer the most.
Yeah.
So you also wanted to talk about the
regressive left.
Of course.
I'd say out of our,
out of our 1200,
out of our 1200 emails,
I'd say about a thousand of them did
have the phrase a regressive left.
So how has this regressive ideology
affected your life in Turkey?
Talking on a TV show?
Like A,
I keep getting angry and angry because
they,
I'm telling blind telling countries,
for example,
that a hominid meant.
They say Turkey is a harmony between
palm tree.
I mean whenever someone criticized Islam
they say it's the perfect example and
you say all Muslims,
but here is 39 to align.
So you're a bigot,
you're understandable.
But the reality is much different than
that.
I mean there is a struggle between the
centers and the Islamists.
And it's not just like,
and whenever you see like something
about it on the media,
it's presented like he's holding those
asshole stitches,
like there's a data and he's doing
whatever.
He has a shooting hold from society.
I mean 50 percent of people supposedly
lost lumping.
They just support and love him.
So at the same time we have second that.
So it's just a constant battle between
us.
So it's not just a,
a,
a harmonious coexistence.
Yeah.
This keeps telling lies about it.
And you know,
I want to say something wrong.
For example,
I always see someone speaking with
confidence around to villages and that
kind of stuff.
But then I see people from the left in
the western countries want cherishing
the western values in malls and they
stopped talking,
reading,
getting capable of defending university
to be random.
So I can't get it.
What's wrong with you?
What's wrong with these liberals in the
West?
I wish I knew what was wrong with them
because it would solve a lot of my
personal problems.
I mean,
I don't know.
So.
But how big is that ideology?
They're like,
so you have,
you have the Islamists,
they,
okay,
we get what they're about.
And then you have the secularists.
How big is that,
that piece that is this sort of
regressive thing
you mean?
Well,
how big is the regressive part?
That's sort of trying to quiet the
secularist because we know that the
Islam Mr.
trying to quiet the secularist,
right?
Well,
you know,
uh,
we don't have the,
we don't have enough conflict to be
regressing,
right?
We don't have any real aggressive in our
country,
but regressives cheap helping to Islam
in the West and uh,
to do not,
I mean are guns in Bangladesh,
Benin in Saudi Arabia,
a mentalist and countries.
They are getting to that by machetes and
people keep talking about,
I mean,
over wearing a book,
is it arrived or,
or what does that or people keep talking
about.
But Mr and that kind of stuff.
I mean,
this really makes me angry because
people are fighting for freedom here and
people,
uh,
like the losing their lives.
And then I see people living in comfort
and a colon.
People even people like me is I've been
called by a Westerner,
Islamophobia for bad times,
even though I'm living in Turkey,
I was pulled into.
Right.
Your living in it.
They're living in the,
in the comforts of the West and they're
calling you in Islam.
But listen man,
we,
we could,
we could go on forever.
We could go on forever here,
but unfortunately we got to keep
rolling,
but it really,
it was a pleasure talking to you
one.
Thanks for submitting.
All right,
we'll talk again.
Alright,
I'm on with Bashir in Jordan.
Bashir.
Has It gone?
Doing well.
Thank you.
Thank you for having me.
My pleasure.
I'm doing great.
Uh,
all right.
So you're the third one up.
We're,
we're dancing across the globe here.
You know Jordan,
one of the things when I saw your email,
you're actually the only person from
Jordan that emailed and we never really
hear anything about Jordan.
You hear about the Middle East
constantly,
everyday in the news.
Something terrible is happening in the
Middle East.
But Jordan,
you don't hear much.
The king comes here and he has a nice
suit and looks good and everything.
That's pretty much all you hear about
Jordan.
So tell me a little bit what,
what's going on in Jordan?
Well,
yeah.
Um,
I think,
uh,
Jordan's like the eye of the storm and
when do you have a storm?
Nobody speaks about the eye of the storm
because it doesn't do anything.
So all the damage is happening all
around us,
but Jordan is pretty safe and nothing
really happens.
Um,
except we keep taking in refugees from
all over and the latest numbers.
I've looked at almost a third of
Jordan's populations,
actually refugees,
including my family.
We came from Palestine,
uh,
after the,
you know,
the first,
uh,
issues with Israel after the Second
World War.
So yeah,
my family is included in that number.
Are you?
Do you have full rights to Palestinians
and Jordan have full rights?
They can't,
they can't vote in certain things or
have certain jobs or something.
Well that's a tough one.
There's so many regulations.
So my family has been here from the
start,
so I'm kind of okay.
But Palestinians who have come later do
have some issues,
especially with the,
like you said,
and the legal system,
they're not fully protected,
so to speak.
Yeah.
How do you feel in terms of,
so you,
you emailed me,
you're,
you're doing this right now,
like just in the general terms of being
able to speak your mind and not worry
about government coercion or anything
like that.
Like do you feel pretty comfortable?
Um,
uh,
I think I do.
I stopped really bothering with it too
much.
It start,
you know,
it was really difficult to start
speaking out and eventually you find
your own circles and at some point
there's a tipping point where you just
don't care anymore about the
consequences.
You're,
you just fight for what you think is
right.
And this is one of the reasons I love
your show and I love you and I admire
you for what you're doing.
Thanks.
Um,
all right.
So you gave me a bunch of great stuff to
talk about here.
One of the things you want it to focus
on was the western apologists for Islam.
Now obviously,
yeah,
obviously I've spent a lot of time
talking about it,
right.
And I always try to separate,
you know,
the,
the Muslim people,
uh,
from the doctrine of Islam.
It's very hard to do as we know.
Uh,
but yeah,
go ahead.
Do the Western apologist.
You're in a Muslim majority country
having to live under certain laws
dictated by Islam.
So what do you make of these people in
the West that are apologizing for this?
Well,
I'll just start out by saying like,
even your distinction is sometimes a bit
blurry,
like even when you separate Muslim
peoples and the doctrine of Islam.
I think there's still some muddy areas
in between.
Sure.
I mean,
sure,
all of us want to be nice and peaceful,
but at the same time when you're in a
conflict and you expect the other site
to be as nice as you,
that's I think a bit silly.
You don't walk up to a lion with a
flower expect there'll be friends
forever.
So yeah,
that doesn't work.
Um,
so,
uh,
the,
the western amount apologists is,
my problem with them is by focusing on
they miss direct the problems and the
issues and as if it's like,
no,
it's not as bad,
you know,
I'm sure like people like Reza,
Aslan and the young Turks,
sorry from bringing data,
but what they practically do is the,
the,
the effect on the good people like
yourself and like the classical liberals
or whoever is genuinely caring about
what's happening in the Middle East and
the Muslim majority countries,
they take the conversation away and it
alleviates this sense of urgency.
They just kill it.
Like if you want it to help and then you
hear someone who claims to be a scholar
and like he knows everything on the
inside and they tell you that no,
it's all fine then.
Yeah,
I don't feel the urge to help anymore.
And for us on the inside,
we see this almost on a daily basis.
I mean female genital mutilation,
homophobia and all the terrible things
people just genuinely dislike in the
west.
These are real problems and we would
appreciate the help from,
you know,
from everybody.
We can help,
right?
So in a way,
so your,
your in like a particularly,
uh,
I guess tenuous situation because
you're,
you're clearly,
I assume you identify as a classical
liberal or a liberal or some or
something you stand for basically
Western values I sense,
right.
Uh,
and,
and you,
you sort of need the help of the
outsiders to,
to make change there because it would be
very hard to do on your own.
Right.
Well,
you know,
of course to help would be much
appreciated,
but when there is,
what's the opposite of helping,
they're just not helping at all and
they're actually making everyone else
feel like there's no problem,
there's no problem then well what are
you going to do?
The problem is going to keep on
escalating until it just blows up.
So I don't,
I,
it's,
it's a tough question I think because I
mean sure that help would be needed but
not ruining it for us would be also
appreciated.
Right.
So on a day to day basis,
living in Jordan,
like how much is religion affecting?
Well,
are you religious at all?
Do you have any religious?
I'm not.
Yeah,
So how much religious religiosity,
religiosity,
what's the word there?
How much of that are you?
Yeah,
I think I got something close.
Um,
how much of that is affecting your day
to day life?
Well,
my day to day life isn't really a
problem for me,
but uh,
if you look at other segments of society
like women or homosexuals or you know,
any kind of a traditionally marginalized
group because Jordan is still a very
patriarchal society.
I'm like,
what?
Feminists in the US,
right,
right.
Yeah.
So I mean,
being a woman,
if you walk down the street,
you're expected to be dressed
appropriately,
which is pretty much covered up and it's
not really strict like in Saudi Arabia
where you have to wear the veil.
It's not like that,
but like don't show legs or,
you know,
so it's kind of moderate in that sense.
Um,
the religiosity is pretty much
everywhere.
Like um,
you always see these verses from the
Koran or somewhere in the streets.
You always hear the call to prayer five
times a day.
Um,
so,
and it's part of our language.
We always say like,
you might've heard this phrase,
inshallah,
of course.
So yeah,
a lot of the profit always come into
these traditional phrases.
We don't probably mean it to be
religious,
but it's just ingrained in us and yeah,
it's just an escapable really.
But I mean it's not as bad as elsewhere,
so that's some hope for us.
Yeah.
Well this was quick weight.
We're basically wearing the same shirt.
I just realized it's pretty close.
Oh,
so we're in good company.
Listen,
I could go way,
way longer with you,
but we got to go your third out of,
out of 20,
but it was a pleasure talking to you and
let's stay in the loop and I hope to get
Jordan one day.
Well you're always welcome.
Great.
Thank you so much.
Don't tell us you're gay though.
We'll keep it quiet.
Keep it quiet door.
Alright,
I'm here with Felix in Germany.
Felix,
you dressed for the occasion.
Finally.
Somebody that's looking sharp.
That's nice to see.
Thank you.
I mean you always dressed very well,
so I thought I dressed up for location
as well.
Very nice.
You went up.
Me with the Thai next time maybe I'll
see what I can do.
All right.
So we got a lot of responses from
Germany,
I'd say after probably the United
States,
UK,
maybe Canada,
and then India.
I think Germany was right there in the
top five.
So you're,
you're the one that we selected from
Germany.
Uh,
so tell me what's going on in Germany
these days.
I mean the biggest thing is obviously
the refugee crisis and the whole
political fear that is surrounding that.
So kind of all it is in trouble because
we have people who don't agree with
established politicians and established
politicians fighting each other.
So it's really interesting times.
Yeah.
So we've talked about it a little bit.
Basically you guys have let in about one
point $3 million,
uh,
immigrants or migrants or refugees,
whatever you want to call them.
You guys give them some pretty great
social services,
right?
It seems like they get a lot.
So what,
what is the problem?
What is,
is there an integration problem?
Is it more from the German side?
Is it from their side?
Is it both?
Is it economics?
What's going on?
See Dave,
I would say it's not a problem with
either the Jamon locals on the migrants
or refugees themselves.
It's a problem or systems.
The government lead in all these
immigrants who are not necessarily all
refugees because there's really no
proper control who gets in and who
doesn't and they sought out later and a
process that takes months until the
whole asylum application goes through
and then we take and one point 3 million
of them,
but there's no system to give them
shelter effectively to integrate them,
to teach them about the German culture.
So what we get a lot of people bunched
up in a really small place who come from
different cultures than our home culture
and then found their own little
subcultures and don't integrate very
well because they have nobody to really
talk to except for the old people.
Yeah.
So does Germany have a sort of a special
place in this?
Because of the history with Germany and
obviously xenophobia and World War Two
in Germany has done a tremendous amount
to to repair that in.
The culture has completely changed.
I think that's very obvious,
but that there's a certain amount of
guilt that you want to do the right
thing and then they come here and then
the systems as you're saying or just not
in place.
So it's like the idea doesn't quite
match up with the reality of what's
going on.
That's exactly what's happening in
Germany.
We have a certain type of unique
political correctness and that we really
still have the shame or the guilt and
wanted to redeem ourselves basically,
even though we are homeless,
two generations removed from the events,
but most Germans stove feel the need to
be proper to other people and to help
others so that the good will of helping
these people and naturally people who
come from civil war,
written areas,
there is a feeling off.
You have to help them out.
But I think the way we are doing it now
is really failing those people in need
and have this also failing the people
locally in Germany.
Yeah.
So let's talk a little bit about,
uh,
what happened on New Year's day in
Cologne because I thought that was sort
of a perfect example of why this whole
debate is so crazy.
So there were these massive attacks that
mostly it sounds like they were mostly
done by migrants,
uh,
assaulting women that were raped and all
this stuff.
And I saw the reaction of the left here
immediately was saying,
God,
this is Islamophobia and all of this
stuff that we,
we talk about endlessly.
And really it didn't have anything to do
with that.
If a group,
if any group had attacked a whole bunch
of women,
uh,
I would have been against that group.
How was the reaction in Germany to that?
Because it sounded like it took a couple
of days for it actually to catch on.
Right?
And then people didn't really want to
talk about it.
Well,
it almost took a few weeks because the
fact that those groups who assaulted
than women were mainly immigrants was
hidden away from the public essentially
by a political officials and police.
And the reaction was quite interesting
because people were really afraid.
And really angry about the situation and
some on the left that the same as
leftists in America and try to put it
away from Islam as a religion or
culture.
And then on the right,
a lot of people blame Islam or Muslims
in general for that,
which is obviously also way too extreme,
but kind of the center is missing where
we acknowledged the problem that there
are cultural differences and if you put
young males who come from this culture,
I've been growing up in this culture,
put them in a place and just let them
have their own communities without any
integration that these problems can
occur and we'll look you.
And that's where we have no solution for
it because we can't acknowledge the
problem.
Yeah.
So with everything you've said so far,
do you guys have a particular sort of
fear of the right wing parties growing
because because of the history of your
country that you don't want these,
the Zena phobic people to actually take
power.
And then at the same time,
as we talked about all the time,
if the left doesn't deal with these
issues,
honestly,
it almost seems like the average person,
the person that's in the middle that
you're talking about,
well then they go to where the only
answer is being spoken of,
even if it's not something they agree
with.
That's exactly right.
And that's what we've been seeing.
I mean,
that's always a move from the
established politicians to band,
the few very right wing parties,
um,
that,
that we'd still have in Germany,
which are really extreme,
at least some of them are.
And they always try to bend them via the
legal system.
But now what the channel of for Germany,
the afd in Germany,
that's a new party,
it sprung in.
All this controversy in Dave become
very,
very big and a lot of people jump onto
that opportunity.
But at the same time,
a lot of right wing extremist obviously
jumped on that.
And the established politicians all try
to pay in this new party,
which is more conservative,
more right wing into the Nazi Kona to
isolate them.
But then of course said you get a lot of
extremists who join that party and you
don't find the real discourse.
Yeah.
So one of the things that you wrote that
I thought it was really,
really great.
So first off,
you're starting a podcast with a
Hungarian friend.
Is He,
is he in Germany or is he in Hungary or
somewhere else?
So we just in Hungary,
we've impersonal.
We've only met once when I was at a time
where you connected through the Internet
just by chance.
I met him one day and we started talking
and talking and talking and because we
both felt the need to speak out about
politics,
about philosophy,
about our societies and to discuss how
we can make them better.
Uh,
we started having night long discussions
literally through the night until the
sun came back up and at some point we,
through shows like yours where you
really emphasized the need to make your
voice heard.
We decided we have to do something and
we decided to basically start a podcast
to get other people in to discuss that
stuff with us and to develop our
opinions openly and to kind of make a
difference.
Yeah.
Well listen,
I love that.
And if every single person that watched
this show started their own show and I
became completely irrelevant,
but the idea is one I would be,
I'll be happy to retire on a,
on a farm in Wyoming or something.
So one of the phrases that you used in
your email to us was the difference
between a global network and a local
network.
And I,
I thought this concept was really cool
because it's very much what we're doing
here and it's why I wanted to do this
fashion show and we have 20 people I
think in 18 countries or so,
or 15 countries.
Uh,
so can you describe what you meant by
that concept?
So a lot of our local networks like
universities,
schools,
but cities and even countries are very
isolated.
We,
we have a consensus usually in those
networks,
in universities,
in America for example,
you have all the social justice warriors
having a real consensus and a lot of
power,
so you can't,
I think as a modern human,
you can't rely on that to get a full
picture.
So these global networks that are
enabled by the Internet,
our really Ed,
where you can get your ideas challenged,
where you can get new ideas,
where you can exchange ideas and that's
where you develop the good stuff.
Yeah.
Well I love that.
It's very much a concept that I believe
in and that I'm trying to put into
action and uh,
we got to go,
but definitely let me know when the
podcast is up.
Just email us again.
I'll be happy to send people over there
and I'll be a guest if you want.
How about that?
Oh,
that would be amazing.
It's actually up now.
We're on episode four now.
Nice.
And you can that on a needlessly
complicated.com
on,
on itunes and everything else.
And if you want to be honest,
I'm happy to.
I guess I am happy to send you an email.
You'd be the host.
I'll be the guest.
How about that?
Alright,
so I am with Monica in Paris,
France and Monica,
you know,
I got a zillion people that emailed from
Paris,
but your bio,
your bio,
just where you've bounced around from a
little bit of your family's history.
There was so much there that you were
the winner from Paris.
Oh cool.
Thanks.
Alright.
So first off just tell me,
so you told me that you grew up with two
atheist parents,
but that,
that was also colored with a Mexican
tradition and a Jewish tradition.
Can you just explain some of that?
Yes.
So my mom is from Mexico.
She's from a city to the north of Mexico
City and she emigrated to the United
States as a baby and my dad is of
Russian Ashkenazi descent and they both
met in university.
They've always been atheist,
both of them and they raised me and my
sister not to be atheist,
but religion has never played a part of
our lives and yet we were raised between
the two cultures,
which was quite difficult growing up in
Arizona and California.
We were never Mexican enough to be
Mexican,
never white enough to be white.
So it was an interesting experience.
Right.
I'm very grateful for it.
Yeah,
that's really cool.
So then you bounced around pretty much
all over the world.
So can you give me like a one minute
synopsis of just where you've bounced
around and then we'll dig into some of
the things that you want to talk about?
Yeah,
sure.
So I lived in Argentina for about a year
and 2012 after that.
Um,
I lived in Israel for awhile and now I
live in France,
so I lived in a few different countries.
Okay.
So let's go to some of the reasons that
you've bounced around.
So you met an Israeli and you move to
Israel and then you were there during
the Gaza War of 2014,
I think.
Yeah.
During protective edge,
protective edge.
So tell me a little bit about what it's
like to be in a country that is at war.
Uh,
it was really scary.
So I still remember the very first time
I heard a missile,
I was watching a show on my laptop and I
heard an explosion and I didn't really
think anything of it.
And then I heard more explosions and
then there were sirens and I had no idea
what to do.
I was living in a small house that
didn't have a bomb shelter.
So,
um,
I ran outside,
my neighbors told me to run into bomb
shelter next door and I,
I couldn't have known.
But then after that for the following
months,
it just became the norm,
like at least minimum seven times a day.
I found myself in a bomb shelter and I
was an English teacher at the time and
um,
a lot of our class time was spent
learning in bomb shelters.
Yeah.
So what,
what's that like being around kids when
this is happening?
I mean,
you're literally,
I assume every school they're probably
has a bomb shelter,
right?
Like so the middle,
the day you're teaching
and then suddenly we all have to run
downstairs.
Yeah.
So the kids know the drill.
The kids are a yearly desensitized to
it.
It's just the norm for them,
you know,
inside the bomb shelters we have
teaching materials and it was like
everything just kind of kept going like
normal for them.
It's just part of their everyday.
Yeah.
So then okay,
so you were there for that and then you
moved to Paris and you were in Paris
during the Paris attacks,
right?
Yeah,
so Charlie Hebdo happened just months
after me arriving and my initial
reaction was disappointment because I
left Israel to kind of get away from all
that a danger.
And then I found myself in the middle of
it again.
I was shocked.
I was really,
I felt really angry.
And then the way people reacted to an
attack like that in Paris was so
different than the way Israelis would
have reacted.
So that's one of the things that I
thought was really interesting.
So you mentioned that,
that basically a lot of people said,
oh,
we're defending Charlie Hebdo,
but that really privately,
that's not really what they were doing.
Right?
Yeah.
So there was like a protest where people
went out in the street and they were
like holding up pencils and I didn't
want to participate in anything like
that because I'm just thinking like the
people who shot these cartoonists and
shot these artists,
we're not trying to take away their
pencils,
like they were trying to kill them.
It has nothing to do with your ability
to write or draw a cartoon like they
want to murder people.
So I just felt like the reaction was
very soft and I'm just very different
than the Israeli reaction would've been.
So what,
what would the Israeli reaction be?
I mean,
they are dealing with pretty much every
day.
Really?
Yeah.
I think we all know what the Israel,
yeah,
reaction would have been,
would have been something.
Um,
that's probably most of the world
wouldn't have been very happy with that.
Most of the world would protest against,
um,
and something that I would have
protested against before I lived in
Israel.
When I went to Israel I was,
I wouldn't have described myself as pro
Israel,
but now I would because it's just very
different when you have missiles flying
over your head and if it wasn't for
that,
um,
iron dome interception system,
you know,
they could just fall on your head and
kill you and all your friends and
family.
So it changed my perspective completely.
Yeah.
Interesting.
So,
okay,
so then you were there for Charlie Hebdo
then,
then the more recent attacks at the
theater.
How has that changed a society because
it does seem like that attack and then
Brussels.
Uh,
and then we had the thing here in San
Bernardino that now there is some
piecing this all together across the
globe.
And I think it really felt like it
started with that one.
I'm from San Bernardino by the way,
is all getting very close to home for
me,
man.
You really are.
Okay.
So the most recent attack was a very
unsettling same.
My,
I had the same feeling towards the
French reaction that I did for Charlie
Hebdo,
kind of just disappointment in the,
the lack of,
um,
I don't know,
have like a strong reaction.
It was more just like a soft reaction
that we have to protect people who
haven't even been insulted yet.
Everybody was just worrying about
hurting a certain group of people's
feelings instead of actually trying to
get to the root of the problem.
Yeah.
How deep is that?
How deep is that feeling in France that.
Because that,
I mean,
that's what we talked about when we
talked about this regressive ideology
that we care more about feelings over
facts.
How much does that sort of seeped into
society over there?
I would say probably even more so than
in America.
Um,
people here are very concerned about
being politically correct.
I'm in a country that has a very high,
a percentage of north Africans and
Muslims.
People are very careful to choose their
words.
The media,
um,
is very careful about what they say and
how they say it,
which is a good thing and a bad thing.
But I would say that now things have
kind of died down,
honestly.
People have kind of forgotten about it.
Security is very lax everywhere.
Um,
they still have some like emergency
procedures in place ever since Charlie
Hebdo,
so it's been almost two years that we've
had these emergency procedures.
They're supposed to be in place,
but like private and public security and
Francis just not where it should be.
Yeah.
So the other thing that I wanted to talk
to you about or that you mentioned is
that there's,
there's two things happening in France
right now.
So one is,
is the immigration situation,
uh,
so you have all these migrants coming in
and then at the same time basically
Jewish emigration from France.
So Jews leaving France is at an all time
high.
I was actually in Israel in November and
I heard a tremendous amount of French
being spoken there.
I couldn't believe it.
I mean,
there were signs in French.
All the places that were selling houses
were written in Hebrew and in French.
Um,
so what,
what's going on there?
So I can't speak too much about,
um,
the immigration of refugees to France
because honestly,
when you hear about it on the news,
but it doesn't affect me at all.
I don't see them.
It just doesn't play a role in my life.
So I can't really speak on that.
But,
um,
I have been very involved in the French
Jewish community,
so I know how they feel about the
situation in France and in Israel.
So there's kind of this feeling and the
French Jewish community,
I don't want to say I'm not a victim
hood,
but,
uh,
they're very closed a network of people
like in the Paris area and um,
they always feel targeted and they feel
like Israel is kind of like this
Eldorado.
It's like this thing that they idolize
and it's like this ideal utopia that
they all want to,
uh,
strive to be a part of.
So every time there's an attack,
it's like the percentage of French Jews
that leave France just skyrockets.
But then another interesting phenomenon
is that when I was in Israel,
I met so many people who leave Israel
after intending to settle.
They're just like I did.
There's actually a word in Hebrew for
that.
It's called Marita.
So Alia is when you immigrate to Israel
to go live there supposedly forever.
Then there's even a word to describe
leaving there forever because you just
can't handle the quality of life.
So French people encounter that.
They leave.
I'm hoping to find this,
a network of acceptance and like living
amongst Jews just going to be amazing
and then they get there and realize that
they were kind of sold a dream and a lot
come back.
Yeah.
So it's sorta like the grass is always
greener.
You have it one way then you think.
Okay,
it's going to be better over there.
Um,
all right,
well you've given me a lot and we're,
we're plowing through all these
interviews,
but it was a pleasure talking to you and
uh,
and good luck with the rest of your
adventures.
Thank you so much.
All right,
I'm on with Ferran in Canada.
Aaron,
how are you?
I'm good,
thanks.
How are you doing guy?
I'm doing well.
I've been enjoying talking to all these
great people.
So,
uh,
what's going on up in Canada these days?
How's Canada?
Oh,
Canada's fine.
Uh,
not as libertarian leanings.
I'd like to turn myself,
but uh,
I'm working on it.
Uh,
I,
I'm uh,
I work with a organization called
students for liberty and I'm currently
going through training to be kind of in
charge of the,
uh,
Canada.
A sect of students for liberty.
So working towards liberty.
Yeah.
Well,
as you know,
I've kind of been into libertarianism
lately.
I think it's very close to classic
liberalism,
which is really where I consider myself
a.
But speaking of your political leanings,
my producer told me just a minute before
we connected that apparently you're in
breitbart related to something about
Milo.
Yes.
I just read the article this morning.
Can you tell me what it is?
He literally just screamed something in
my ear and then ran off.
Sure.
While the name of the articles,
like a,
it's called Chinese for trump and it's
basically talking about trans woman who
a,
either like Donald Trump or support him
fully.
I don't fully support him,
but I liked him in many ways and I think
his presidency could in some ways
actually be helpful.
Yeah.
But that's a strange place to be for a
libertarian,
right?
Because he seems to be a big government,
more of a liberal guy.
But I think you like the,
you like the sort of trolling
unpolitical,
correct.
I don't,
I don't agree with his trade policies.
I think that their economic 10 letter at
A.
I don't have a particularly strong
stance on his immigration policies.
Uh,
yeah.
So I'm not,
I don't really like that.
And uh,
I read an article just the other day
that uh,
if he comes with his president,
if he becomes president,
that things like taxes to be resent and
minimum wage would.
So not that much.
It's a strange place for a libertarian.
I don't support him,
but there are certain parts of him that
I like.
Um.
All right.
So you gave me a lot on your,
on your email entry.
So let's,
let's dive right into it.
So first of all,
you're a men's rights activist,
correct?
Yes.
So can you explain what that means
because I think a certain set of people
get that and then another set think that
something crazy and then,
but I think the bulk of people just
don't even understand what that means.
So a lot of people don't necessarily
realize that they're not informed about
the fact that men are falling behind or
are discriminated against in many ways
in today's society,
in,
in Canada,
in America,
whether it's the high suicide rates,
whether it's the high rates of
homelessness,
uh,
whether it's um,
you know,
men kind of getting the short end of the
stick legally nowadays with all these
rape cases.
Um,
and uh,
and,
and then there's domestic violence,
which is also a huge problem and men
really don't get seen.
And the statistics on the knowledge on,
on,
on the true,
the reality of domestic violence isn't
really,
isn't really known to most people.
So I,
I'm,
I'm not an,
I'm more than just an advocate.
I'm an activist.
I lead a men's rights group on my campus
at Simon Fraser University and uh,
we host monthly events inviting
different people with different
perspectives on men's issues.
Uh,
we had Karen Straughn and uh,
uh,
I listened to him and last month and
they have this coming up month.
We're having a panel discussion event on
different perspectives of the
masculinity from men going their own way
to mythic poetic,
which you probably don't know if you're
not into the man's married Merryman,
and then there's the feminist
perspective.
So we're going to hold up,
have a whole panel discussion.
So it's really about boots on the ground
activism.
I'm really engaging with people,
so I'm kind of taking the online.
I'm one of the people taking online's
fail offline and trying to raise
awareness one on one.
Yeah.
So I think for the average person
watching this that doesn't know much
about these issues,
they're probably looking at you and
saying,
wait a minute,
here's a trans woman into men's rights
issues.
That kind of flips everything on its
head.
Does that give you a certain cache
within the community?
Um,
I think that,
um,
it gives me a lot of freedom to say what
is churn without being labeled a
misogynist or sexist or this or that.
I said a lot of things that if some
average white guy said it,
he would be maligned a,
I think my being trans has helped a lot
for our club in the sense that we
haven't been protested much.
We have,
while we haven't protested at all,
we haven't got too much backlash and I
think it's because in the kind of
regressive mindsets,
uh,
attacking a group that's led by what is
in their minds and oppressed minority
would be oppressing the minority.
Even thought that.
Yeah.
So you're sort of like Kryptonite in a
way to them because because they judge
you not by your individual ideas.
Right?
But they're judging you as solely a
trans person.
They know the trans person is high on
the oppression Olympics chart,
so then they can't really figure out how
to attack you versus you're able to
protect your own ideas.
I mean,
it's,
it's actually kind of genius and also
bonkers.
Well,
well it's genius on.
Yes,
bonkers.
I kind of realized that very early on,
I realized when I realized that the
reality of men's issues and how there
isn't much a lot of spokespeople for men
and men who suffer a,
I realized that if,
if not me,
who are and who better than a
transwoman,
I realized right away the position I'm
in and how I would be squandering a
really great opportunity.
So I totally,
I totally use my identity as a trans
woman to further men's rights and I'm
not really ashamed of it because I want
to help men and I want to further their
discretion.
Yeah.
So obviously I get the part that you've
sort of insulated yourself from some of
the criticism,
but when you do get the criticism,
it,
does it feel particularly personal to
you because you're trans and that,
uh,
I talked to another trans person,
that sort of like the thing of the
moment.
Um,
no,
I,
I don't know.
I criticism I get from kind of the
regressive side.
Um,
I don't know.
They don't generally try to really steer
away from the fact that I'm trans.
A lot of them.
The criticism that has been launched at
our club haven't even recognized me as
the president then kind of try that.
It wouldn't touch with a 10 foot pole.
Um,
I mean I get criticism for being a
female men's rights activists in
general.
I mean,
there are other people could take issue
with that because it's just kind of
perpetuating a,
you know,
everyone focusing on women.
Are there other women in the group?
Yes.
It's actually our,
our executive team is a three women and
one guy.
I mean,
that's really fascinating.
Yeah.
Uh,
I find women or are law,
uh,
it's a lot easier for them to approach,
let's say we're titling at club does so
much easier for them to approach our
table and start discussing and they
don't fear A.
I find a lot of men are kind of a kind
of weary,
uh,
they're very afraid that they're going
to be judged as a certain,
you know,
as they're going to be judged as
misogynistic or sexist or why are you,
why are you associating with those
people?
So it's actually quite a bit easier to,
um,
to attract women.
But then when I hear about the men who
are,
who do come talk to us,
uh,
the men who kind of stir up the bribery,
I have quite horrible stories,
uh,
in our,
from being horribly abused by their
girlfriends or having narcissistic
mothers and fathers.
Then I'm just,
I hear,
I hear already that truth of what's
going on.
Uh,
and yeah,
I would encourage men to,
um,
to come to a protest more because we are
in that sense,
kind of a safe space,
if you will.
I would say spaces,
right?
Uh,
I like,
I,
I'm,
I don't like spices if that means that
you can't talk about certain things,
but that's not really what it means in
all contexts and more means that we want
malign you if you feel certain ways,
if you feel angry because a lot of men
are angry and I understand that anger.
I'm not going to tell them that they're
just misogynists and sexists.
Um,
they're not going to get judged.
They're going to have at least an
understanding.
Yeah.
It's about it.
It's not a safe space of ideas.
It's just a,
a safe space of judgment.
Which are two different things.
It's an understanding,
compassionate space.
How about that?
Yeah.
Um,
so what's,
what's next after this?
So,
you know,
when you get out of school,
is this something that you want to
pursue it at a career level or are you
interested in other things altogether?
Well,
I'm currently finishing up my music
composition degree,
which is completely separate from what
I'm doing,
but I actually want to go into law and
probably constitutional law.
But um,
I think in,
in,
in my past and law,
I can,
I'm definitely influenced some real,
at least legal challenge,
uh,
where it helps men and,
but also just defending constitutional
rights and,
and you know,
our human rights on a very basic level
and a kind of putting my effort into
keeping the state
small.
That's the libertarian part.
There you go.
Well listen,
we could obviously do a lot more,
but unfortunately we gotta we gotta cut
it short,
so I really enjoyed talking to you and
uh,
good luck with everything.
I enjoyed talking to you as well.
Um,
thank you so much for the opportunity
Dave.
Alright,
I'm on with Tomi from the UK.
Tommy,
has it gone?
Very good.
Thank you very much.
How are you?
I'm doing well.
Uh,
so your story,
you know,
everyone's sending me these great sort
of life stories and what they want to
talk about.
There was something interesting
right at the beginning of yours.
You're originally from Nigeria and you
moved to the UK the day before nine
slash 11.
So you moved on September 10th,
2001.
Can you describe a little bit of that?
Yeah.
Um,
when I first got the news about that I
was a topical double decker,
you know,
the sort of British buses.
Sure.
What the,
the two stage,
the two level of bosses are the top of
that and that's when we heard the news
about that something has happened in New
York and some explosion of something
about abusers.
And then we go home and then I sort of
saw the peaches about all of what
happened and you know,
it didn't,
I didn't really understand the gravity
of what had happened.
I mean,
I understood it was,
you know,
horrible thing.
Um,
and uh,
many people died book,
it wasn't years,
so he is elated.
I sort of really understood,
I,
you know,
the world has changed in any radical
way.
So that was sort of my,
my earliest memory coming into the UK.
Um,
so in a sense of sort of a baptism of
fire sorts.
Yeah.
Talk about a crazy time to move to the
west.
So let's back up a little bit.
Tell me a little bit about growing up in
Nigeria.
What,
what kind of family you came from and
what made you guys move to the UK or do
or did you move by yourself?
I'm actually on it.
No,
I moving,
I'm moving my father,
my mother,
my mother.
My mother is a nurse.
She wasn't as many as Nigeria.
I'm going to say she because of you,
you do know we have an nhs.
Yeah.
And there's a high demand for nurses in
the UK.
So she moved over to the UK about two
years before we moved to join her on.
My father was a journalist and used to
be an editor in oil and gas magazine in
Nigeria.
So we moved together and myself,
my younger brother would move together
with him on and we moved basically,
essentially to have the best education
in the UK,
um,
antidote our mother.
And so that was,
you know,
a little bit.
It's my family.
It's true.
Yeah.
What,
what was life like in Nigeria?
People,
you know,
you hear about Nigeria but we don't know
really.
At least here in the West or in the US,
we don't talk about Nigeria that much.
Tell me a little bit about what it was
like,
um,
growing up in Nigeria,
life was fun.
Um,
you know,
you out there with your friends playing
it was in a child,
childhood was the best time,
you know,
can the world.
Although during the time when I was
going in Nigeria growing up in Nigeria,
we had the dictator,
general sunny.
I betcha.
Um,
and he,
he was a very ruthless guy.
Um,
you know,
destroyed the country to meet a lot of
ways economically embezzled a lot of
money.
But Nigeria is a very resilient.
They are probably the most resilient
people in the world,
you know,
you put them in the middle of the Sahara
desert,
they start sending you sand say so
Nigeria's a very resilient.
So we,
we,
we got through,
we survived,
we did well,
you know,
went to school and things like that.
Um,
but towards me,
towards the time I was coming to the UK,
he passed away and there was massive
parties in the streets and everything
like that.
So,
uh,
yeah,
so that starts how much hated he was.
Um,
and then did another dictator come in
right after him.
I don't even know the history
after that we had a civilian,
um,
uh,
we had the office democracy after many
years of,
of going through,
um,
generals and dictates is basically.
And so we had a passenger will become
president and he ruled,
boy,
he was also corrupt in many ways.
Um,
and,
and he's also from the same tribe that I
am in Nigeria,
but many from my partner and Andrea
especially,
my dad didn't like it because it was not
a fan man.
So,
um,
we had that,
but now we were a country that's
struggling a lot.
We just had our,
our president's going to the UK for some
anticorruption socks and he's trying to
give back some money because the country
has been really hammered by,
by previous regime is basically.
Yeah.
All right.
So let's flash forward to today.
One of the things that you wanted to
talk to me about,
something that we've touched on the show
I'll just a tiny bit,
but brexit,
it's obviously huge for you guys over
there.
Now.
You Support Brexit,
right?
Yes.
I am a big supporter of brexit.
I'm a big supporter of Brazil as an
engineer and I'm a big supporter as a
first generation immigrant out in
support of breast as a British citizen.
And it,
it,
it rests essentially on this principle.
I asked myself this question if I was in
Nigeria and I found that,
that the,
uh,
the political system was controlled by
another political system that was based
in Cairo in Egypt,
and they've made it past our laws.
They told us what to do with our fishes
and in our waters and all that kind of
stuff.
I'd give upset about that.
I'll say,
I'll say that's not fair.
We can't.
Nigeria's should have control over their
own laws and over their own borders and
everything.
So I,
I look at it from a point of view.
He's Nigerian living in Nigeria and this
happens in Nigeria.
How would I feel and tickets to the UK
now that is exactly what is happening to
the UK.
We have a situation whereby we have a
European Commission that is not elected
or passes a law that we have to abide to
and we can vote them out of office.
So it's essentially a sort of a
dictatorial system of sorts.
Yeah.
So how much of your feelings about that
is fueled by just the border situation?
Because one of the things,
I think we've done about 12 interviews
now and one of the things that almost
everyone has wanted to talk to me about
in Europe is the immigration stuff and
the border stuff and the migrant stuff
and all that.
So how much of your feeling is just
wrapped up just in that you want the UK
to be able to control its own borders?
I,
I think that's,
I think that's an,
I think that's a very essential part of
the brexit argument.
But the border,
the border situation is tangential to
the real issue.
And I guess since I'm not an indigenous,
um,
the way I feel about integration might
be slightly different,
but I have a lot of sympathy to
indigenous indigenous.
We are seeing that in,
if they feel the sense that the
country's been overwhelmed and they have
no control over.
So I have an appreciation and I
sympathize with that.
My biggest problem is that if we do not
give us control of over the borders,
it will lead to a situation of social
tensions.
And as soon as he's an immigrant and you
know,
I'm black and I in you don't know.
So,
so,
um,
so as someone who is an immigrant,
I feel like if you create so much social
tension within the system,
it will,
there'll be a backlash.
And so my,
my,
my biggest worry about this whole EU
controller,
neal,
that the control the he puts on
different nations is that it doesn't
allow nations to act autonomously so it
doesn't give them that sort of self will
to,
to do things and that leads to
frustration and that's what we see the
rise of the far right and the far left
in Europe now.
Yeah.
So I'm curious.
So as a first generation immigrant,
it's really interesting.
You're,
you're framing this not only from your
perspective,
but you are looking at the people that
live there before you and sick saying
that they have some legitimate fears or
maybe some of it's not fully legitimate,
but you're acknowledging it.
I'm curious,
has some of the sort of regressive
ideology has that affected you in that?
I think most people would probably look
at you and say that you're black and
that you're an immigrant and that you
should be for fully open borders or some
something along those lines.
I,
I like to see it.
He's a fair minded person and I,
I also like to deal with the realities
of life.
So back nine,
Joanne,
I'm from omb in the late eighties we had
a massive immigration from Ghana,
which is an under a west African nation
into Nigeria because they had an
economic downturn bought that,
put a little pressure on,
on jobs and services in Nigeria,
and they became these chants,
you know,
this,
this movement called gun on goat.
No,
that wasn't a,
a sort of a racist movement,
but in that I could see and appreciate
that whenever you have a massive influx
of immigration open,
showed immigration,
it's under the place.
It leads to social tensions and you can
look at it throughout history and
throughout everywhere in the world.
And so we have to do with this bear the
image.
I'm pro immigration.
Immigration is good,
but it has to be controlled.
It has to be sensitive.
But I mean it has to be at the behest
and at the will of the people.
If not,
it's going to lead to trouble.
And,
and that's,
that's where I think this discussion
needs to be,
to be hard.
Man.
You're talking to a lot of sense.
Why aren't you on TV?
You know,
I,
I don't speak a lot of pc stuff,
so
on that,
on that note,
I'm going to let you go without saying
anything,
but I'm going to let you go without
saying too crazy.
It was really,
it was a pleasure talking to you.
All right.
I am on with Marcello who is in Maine in
the United States via Brazil.
Am I correct?
Yes,
you're right.
I'm from Brazil.
That is quite a move to go from Brazil.
It's hot and now cold.
What people are supposed to go the other
way.
What are you?
Thank you.
Yeah.
I actually lived before he,
Connecticut initially when I moved to
us.
Then I lived one year in Miami,
so I kind of experienced them warm back
and now back in me and it was just
mostly for my work.
Right.
What kind of work do you do?
I'm a physician.
Right,
right.
Okay.
We're going to get into a little bit of
that.
I knew that actually.
Uh,
but.
So one of the things that you wanted to
discuss with me was how regressive
attitudes and this ideology had really
infected Brazil and how you saw it,
a change attitudes in Brazil.
So can you tell me a little bit about
that?
Yeah.
Brazil overall is a pretty hardcore left
leftist country.
The culture in Brazil was taken over by
hardcore socialist in the last about 30
years they took over the church is the,
the press,
the universities,
and uh,
they,
they have this mindset of not wanting to
debate ideas.
So the way that they see things is that
if you're not,
if you don't not agree with them,
then you should shut up.
You should basically get out of the way.
And this is quite concerning because you
see people who had these a will to learn
and getting to debate and,
you know,
and I think that's how country's
progress,
how that's how ideas,
debating ideas.
That's how we get to a Como status to a
place for everyone.
And when you can,
my language,
brother,
there you go.
Um,
and,
and that's actually what caught me to
your show initially.
Uh,
this idea of fighting for free speech
and in Brazil basically the more skilled
and now in la in the last 10 years I
would say there's a conservative
movement surging so small as to not
empower,
but at least there is another way of
thinking kind of surgery and people are
interested,
people are actually looking to it and an
amazing,
Whoa,
this exists,
you know,
like,
oh,
that makes sense.
And that's very interesting.
And it's very unfortunately that went in
that direction.
So that's really fascinating.
So you're saying basically in the last
10 years as a result of this regressive
ideology taking root that now
conservatism is bubbling up and that is
what is defending free speech.
It sounds a little backwards for the way
America is,
although right now I see that happening
here because strangely it's
conservatives that are defending free
speech and the left that's trying to
stifle it.
So it's really everything's kind of
upside down.
No,
I totally agree with you.
And uh,
I'm not sure if there's a direct effect
of that or if it's just,
um,
people really.
When do you read about new ideas?
They get interested even if they don't
agree initially,
when they have had the freedom to do it.
Um,
they,
so there are some thinkers,
some riders in Brazil that 10 years ago
started writing some stuff and that's
when actually I started reading more
about conservatives,
more about America,
the free speech ideas,
the individual rights and the dit of
you're able to see whatever you want and
you're fine if you don't like it,
that's fine.
That's fine.
I like it.
And there's not the way in Brazil
before.
And I saw for example,
journalists actually,
uh,
having to move away from Brazil in order
to be able to speak.
And that's that for me.
It's something unacceptable.
It shouldn't happen.
Yeah.
I have to say that,
uh,
until I read your email,
I really didn't realize how bad things
had been in Brazil.
Uh,
so one of the things that you wrote that
was interesting is that you started
getting interested in conservative
writers and that sort of helped your
awakening.
And now you're saying many years later
these conservative ideas are becoming
cool again down there.
Who were some of the writers that you
were interested in?
Well,
initially I started reading proceeding
on rikers and one of them was a
philosopher called Paul offit,
car carvana.
He'd currently lives in Virginia.
He's well known for,
well known writer in Brazil who actually
had to move away.
He's one of them and he lives in
Virginia.
US.
Um,
he's a big fighter against communism,
socialism in Brazil of free speech for
free speech guy.
I started reading his stuff.
I then started reading American writers
like almost soul,
um,
uh,
Henry House Lit,
and this other guys from other countries
as well and from other Chicago schools
freedom.
And more recently I've been reading a
lot of things that dinesh d'souza
rights.
Um,
so there are few conservatives and they
usually disguise,
they defend free speech,
they defend a free exchange of ideas and
some of them were actually leftist
before,
like a David Horowitz as a hardcore left
blackfoot cysts.
Fomo Saul was a leftist and they,
when he got in contact with the ideas of
conservative,
they kind of Linda the other direction.
Yeah.
I've really been doing my best to get
Thomas,
so the show,
I don't know how much public stuff he
does anymore,
but I'm working on it.
So stay tuned on that one.
Um,
so okay,
so you move up here and you've already
seen the damage that these ideologies
have done in your home country.
So what do you make of what they're
doing to America right now?
It's like seeing a movie again.
Um,
and,
and it actually changed a lot.
I feel like it changed a lot in the
last,
let's say eight years,
seven years since I moved.
I'm not sure why,
but I see happening things that I never
thought it would be possible here when I
moved to America,
saw,
you know,
the universities here are the best
universities in the world.
They probably have very free environment
for new ideas,
for speech,
for debate.
And then a window you see cases like Ms
Dot Arvizu,
uh,
where the professor was saying that's
the muscle here to shut off a student,
a student.
And then you see guys that just to stay
with guys they're interviewed,
they're Shapiro mile being like there
was violence against them and,
and they cannot even speak any morning
campuses.
And your see left is even leftists
powers one of the journalists who wrote
a book about the left shutting up,
Christina,
Christina bars.
So even this guys,
people are.
Wait,
what is,
this is not cool.
This is not,
this is not good for anybody.
So what,
what do you do in your own personal life
to combat this stuff?
I guess this is the example of the right
here and you're talking to me so that.
So that's pretty good.
But really as someone that has seen the
damage of this and you see this
happening now,
is there,
I mean,
do you post stuff on facebook,
the uh,
try to get stuff out there to combat
some of this?
Yeah,
I use my facebook a lot.
I have a lot of American friends.
I have friends.
I'm very political on facebook and I'm
glad that I'm still live in a country
that is very free,
that I'm not afraid.
Like I was in Brazil.
People in Brazil are afraid of speaking
out things against the government.
For example,
I'm here.
No,
I'm,
I,
I feel comfortable.
So I'm very,
I'm very active in facebook and I
usually try to use the experience that I
have in Brazil and,
you know,
push my American friends so they can see
the parallel,
you know,
to try to avoid.
I wouldn't be poor,
but just the American going directions.
Do you have American friends that are
friending you yet and blocking you and
all that kind of keep track of them I
guess.
I guess in some cases you wouldn't know.
Right.
Okay.
So the other thing,
let's move away from politics a little
bit,
although everything is political.
So you mentioned that you're a physician
and one of the things that you want us
to talk about was the free market and
healthcare.
Uh,
we don't have a ton of time left,
but can you just go with that?
Um,
yeah.
Basically just a short thing.
In Brazil we have free healthcare,
meaning the government takes over
everything and that's where exactly
where I see people dying for lack of
basic care.
People waiting in lines for six months
to get an Mri when they have cancer and
a timeline that's very common.
Um,
and I believe that as anything else in
life,
when the free market he's able to share
work,
it works better than the government.
So I think in that sense where you're
going the wrong direction.
We America has a very good healthcare.
We have problems that can be solved.
We have to sit down and see what the
best policies to get.
Um,
but I think the fundamental idea is that
we should go towards more free market
because competition makes prices go
down,
makes things more available services
more available.
I wanted a system that gives us iphone,
new TV,
new cars for cheap.
I don't want a system where she did my
healthcare to bureaucrats who spend
$1,000,000,000
should make a website that doesn't work.
Right.
So for you in the,
in the personal sense as a physician,
how have you seen the healthcare economy
changing the.
I mean it's obviously changed hugely in
the last three years alone.
What have you seen firsthand?
Well,
I,
I work in a hospital,
but I hear it,
I think at the hospital up,
haven't we hadn't had the,
the,
the hip from obamacare yet,
but I see a lot of people who work as an
office outside with,
uh,
outpatient,
retiring because they just couldn't
handle it anymore.
Um,
I see a lot of regulations coming in,
increasing the price is because every
single regulation,
every single pile of new rules costs.
Uh,
so when you,
when you get more government in between
patients and physicians you have,
do you have a more cross?
So prices go up and I've even seen this,
uh,
and we don't have the obamacare fully
implemented yet.
I think there are more things to come
and then make maybe make things even
worse.
Listen,
if I ever need a full frontal lobotomy
because of the regressives,
is that something you can do?
I'm not a neurosurgeon,
but I don't want her to have a lobotomy.
I think are very good fighter for
freedom.
We need you.
All right,
fair enough.
Well listen,
it was a pleasure talking to you.
I wish we had more time,
but we gotta keep going.
It was my pleasure.
Thank you so much for letting me
participate in a show.
All right.
I'm talking with you from Switzerland.
Has It gone?
I'm pretty fine.
Yeah,
I'm fantastic.
Thanks for having me.
Good.
That seems like the answer that someone
from Switzerland would give.
I'm pretty fantastic.
People think everything's great over
there,
Huh?
Well,
life is actually pretty great.
So,
um,
yeah,
everybody's happy around here and we
need to show that.
Yeah,
no,
I like hearing that because,
you know,
we talk about a lot of heavy stuff on
the show,
but it's nice to know that things are
working.
But one of the things that you mentioned
you wanted to talk about is the dreaded
regressive left and how their ideology
is changing society in Switzerland.
So go ahead.
Well,
um,
the regressive left in Switzerland or
the equivalent of them.
Yeah.
They're not really out there in your
face like in other countries,
but the actions speak volumes of course,
you know,
I mean,
they've always been there,
but um,
yeah.
And I keep on staring at the party now.
I mean,
we recently had a case like in the tabby
that's just around the corner from
reality in which you don't,
two boys from a school from Syria with a
very strong religious background refused
to shake hands with a female teacher.
Yeah,
yeah.
You heard about that?
Yeah.
That made news here.
And uh,
you know,
the reason behind that was because they
didn't want to suddenly her dignity's by
touching her rights.
And this of course all stemmed from the
father who is the preaching of a local
mosque.
And yeah,
this a stood quite controversy here and
um,
you know,
and of course,
the reactions were huge,
you know,
I mean we had to write shouting,
I'm all the way down that it's not
acceptable.
And the Ivr and you had left.
I'm playing everything down saying like,
you know,
it's,
it's just a handshake,
you know,
if you want to go and do some
handshakes,
we can go to the streets and do that.
It's not big of the asshole.
Most of all.
They all kept on saying it's against
loads is fine.
Right.
But I think what noise people more and
the reason why they're so passionate
about the whole ot was because,
um,
the decision of the school by just
tolerating that without actually any
article to know,
which is quite an aggressive thing to do
now.
And uh,
you know,
um,
of course concerns were made by the
people by seeing night and they wanted
to start this discussion.
Now it's not particularly about the
handshake itself,
which also refused the moderates in our
country and they're,
they're just asked themselves stuck.
They want to start a question though.
Like what is an acceptable into of
integration?
What is acceptable in terms of religious
freedom,
you know,
and this basic as has been washed out.
But just saying like I'm saying like now
it's not that big a deal,
you know,
it's,
and it also interviewed them.
I'm the head teacher for the school.
And he also kept on saying it's not
against the rules and that's about it.
I just don't want to put ourselves out
there too much.
You know,
and this annoyed quite lot of people
because you know,
the reason why they feel passionate
about this whole ordeal was not because,
you know,
check itself is because the discussion
which has never been actually made,
you know,
this was kind of,
a big deal here around.
Yeah.
So it's not about the actual handshake,
nobody really cares about that,
but it's just about the creeping idea
behind it,
which is that,
that these boys will grow up and not
necessarily respect women or treat women
as equals and then that becomes an
actual societal problems.
So it's not about a bunch of young boys
whether they shake this one person's
hand or not.
Well I think it was more about like,
you know,
what are the ground rules integration
here.
We just want to talk about that and we
don't actually want to talk too much
into the future because we don't know
what actually would happen.
You know,
it was just like let's just talk about
it.
And at some point it was just not
possible edible and it didn't end at
that point.
Actually,
I made the pots capitals 30 and instead
of bringing out,
and there was another recent case in
another city Lucerne,
which is quite a famous this nation in
Switzerland,
but it was actually a dentist,
this dentist who fused to operate on
patients.
The patient happens to be a Muslim woman
and she refused to give him a handshake
because it's,
it's just a thing she doesn't do.
He refused to operate on her because he,
his argument was um,
you know,
I'm a patient doctor relationship is
based on trust.
If the trust is not,
I cannot buy the best wheel and by the
best capabilities of my conscious I
cannot operate on her,
you know,
although of course that this has,
blowing up again,
you know,
like people asking like,
haven't you made something like the
hippocratic oath or something,
you know when you said like,
yes I did.
But the only challenge with them with
emergency status,
you know,
it's,
and,
and she can choose whoever talked to she
actually wants,
you know,
it's actually the same thing just in
opposite positions,
you know,
I mean,
it has closed.
It has no feeling,
you know?
Right.
So this is like with us,
you know,
it's like these bakers that don't want
to bake a cake for a gay wedding and
it's like,
what should the role of the government
be and should we force people to do all
this stuff?
Um,
so one of the other things that you
wanted to talk about was the amount of
Americans that are moving to
Switzerland.
So that's a different type of
immigration that you have going on
there.
Tell me about.
Yeah,
you can see the other side of the story
too.
Yeah.
I mean,
uh,
of course the amount of Americans still
pales in comparison to the EU,
which the most people immigrated come
from,
but they are quite a lot of Americans
coming here because Switzerland supplies
about is home to many and major global
companies.
And of course eventually they get a
chance to come my here and then
themselves next steps program.
So after someone else they can go back
and most of my coworkers actually
decided to stick around a little bit
longer because they learned to
appreciate the high wages on the
security.
And Nice infrastructure to before who
I'm optimistic,
positive.
Of course there are some bad things here
as well.
And you know,
like the depressive Sunday where
everything is closed and the high cost
of living,
but usually they like the social
security network here around and stick
around here.
And uh,
I think is.
I have to tell you a little story,
sorry about that.
We're also,
um,
a household.
We speak a couple of languages,
right?
And we speak also English and before my
tall to enter the kingdom hall.
And she actually,
we had to fill out the form explaining
how good the German was actually.
So the oldest so she can keep up in
school,
you know,
I was just actually,
uh,
yeah,
it's,
it's a sensible thing to do.
And now after the signing of the letter
I received from the Department of
Education,
I received a letter,
an annual let's actually demanding for
me to organize the German classes.
And of course I was actually surprised I
was calling up and asking what's the
reasoning behind this?
Because I do speak Swiss German pretty
well actually.
I'm not bidding cities in consumables.
And she actually was very surprised.
He thought like,
Oh yeah,
you know,
I'm,
I'm sorry about that.
I mistook it for someone else because
you know,
there are some people who have more
issues and I've thought about that.
Yeah,
I my name,
age.
No,
maybe she thought about Asian people
will do actually have some difficulties
learning switch because it's bad.
And she told me,
actually no,
I thought your American,
because I'm American American,
she told me private,
of course the American,
a lot of those people have most
difficulties willing to have most
difficulties and to want students with
German actually because I'm.
One of the reasons is because they just
spent just,
they're just going to be here for five
years and the oldest is just that
reviews are because.
And that's what she said,
you know,
it's like,
um,
yeah,
that's actually no need for us to do
because you can also speak English.
But it's actually true.
Most people actually in the,
in the area to speak English.
It's actually no,
the reverse thing of the whole thing
know.
I mean it's like,
of course not all the Americans.
I mean,
I have many friends who were Americans
this but as a found out and my
surroundings and stuff quite sensitive
because now this whole thing,
interesting and after learning more
about this,
I really found out that there's really
something,
some with some Americans here and not
willingness to assimilating based and
after asking know,
um,
after coding and um,
my uh,
ex employee who happens to work with the
office of statistics inside like,
yes,
because you know,
now something like,
I'm not all of them,
but some of them have something like a
special snowflake syndrome,
you know,
something like that.
Yeah,
we do it all.
Well anyway,
you can speak English,
so why should I know.
Right.
And that's,
that's really fascinating because it
also shows that this,
all this integration stuff and
immigration stuff and migrants stuff,
it's not just about religion,
it's culture because now you're telling
me that Americans are coming there.
It's not because of religion that
they're not integrating,
but it's partly language only going to
be there for five years.
There used to always speaking English
listening.
We could go on way longer and I didn't
get to handle it.
I didn't get to half the stuff I wanted
to talk to you about,
but we got to go so I thank you very
much.
All right.
I'm on with Stefanos from Greece to
Fido's.
How's it going?
It was long.
Like I said previously,
as long as they have it still money in
the bank just by the capital controls
being implemented.
Yeah,
I can still live.
All right.
So that seems like a sort of depressing
but good place to start.
So we don't hear much about Greece in
the American media,
but you guys are going through a massive
financial crisis right now.
So I know,
I know you're not an expert in
economics,
but can you sort of lay it out just what
the average person in Greece is going
through right now?
So let's just say that the minimum wage
here is a 500 euros.
Okay.
And show me one one coast cold that can
live like that.
Just so.
So to me it's impossible.
You can't do that.
And I'm again,
say fine,
it's 500 euros but can't go until he
stops me slightly less,
but no thinks memo dot dms that we other
being imposed by miracle and the rest of
the EU officials and we have to pay like
we have pretty much the taxation of
Germany and the wages and benefits of
Uganda.
Right.
So basically you guys,
because of the conditions that the EU
helped grease out with,
your taxes are very high and you have a
lot of people that are getting a lot
from the government.
So there's not a lot to go around.
Is that pretty much fair to say?
Yeah.
And so it's only the useful to the
number one,
eh,
the ones responsible for this.
It might be no,
use my government,
this,
Theresa and the government that we have
right now.
And they're the ones before them.
New Democracy for example,
if I saw,
etc.
So they're responsible for this.
Yeah.
So how do you feel,
I mean,
in general,
look,
democracy came from Greece.
Modern philosophy came from Greece.
Greece has given so much in terms of
freedom and free thought to the world.
How do you feel about what's happening
in Greece at the moment?
Yeah.
If only that existed here and it goes,
it's a big my 16 extinct species by now
here.
And the problem here is that,
uh,
let's see the elections,
the elections,
you know,
being killed by a gold,
gold singular logic that works with the
government to count all the votes,
etc.
So at the surface it's all fine and
dandy until you get to realize that,
uh,
this company,
it belongs to the old sites.
No,
the ones,
the big bad bankers,
which be honest,
a Canada and there are,
I think behind the scenes of all this
nonsense.
Right?
So You guys are sort of caught between
the european union and the bankers that
are kind of funding the election,
sort of.
Yeah.
They're the oneS benefiting from this
crisis.
Yeah.
All right,
well let's,
let's get away.
Let's get away from politics for a
minute because it obviously can be a
pretty sobering.
Uh,
one of the things you wanted to talk to
me about was gamergate,
which a lot of people jumped on the
gamer gate idea.
Anything specific on gamer gate or how
did you get involved in it?
Were you in it from the beginning
and once you've moved in?
The moment I heard about this story of
having sex with one of the,
the eh,
the journalist in goto when he posted
there,
If you have a quest,
if I'm right that game.
So it is obvious that the,
oh,
this gaming journalism websites I got up
and they all have these feminists.
Dsa was in all these people defend this.
Like why defend this?
The,
they don't care about gamers don't get
up us.
So that,
that's why I was so interested in gamer
gate.
Even before I,
you know,
I used to be a gamer like in the
eighties and nineties and now like I
love the culture around video games but
I don't play that much.
But I thought the whole thing was
fascinating because you guys were
dealing with so much of the stuff that
we talk about now.
The gamers,
we're dealing with all the social
justice warrior stuff,
all the collusion between,
you know,
creators and the publishers and all of
that and feminism and,
and all of this stuff.
And that sort of seeped up into society
which is a good transition for you.
Also wanted to talk about cultural
marxism and I think that's very much
related.
So how has cultural marxism,
the ideas of it taking root in Greece
right now?
Good.
Say that pretty much invented eh
cultural marxism really throuGh the fact
that we have like series a and next
thing,
those are the parties under a.
Yeah,
which is not doing parliament right now.
They get like one percent of the vote or
soMething and the radicals and there was
also also known as the socialist which
uh,
was responsible for the grants that we
live right now.
Like they were promising to people
things that on the surface are needed,
like high wages,
a pensions benefits and all that good
stuff.
But what they do,
well they did,
let's say during the eighties they
tripled that way.
So that's fine.
But they did well not acknowledging that
you to do that,
you have to take some counter measures
as well,
like you have to decrease a taxation for
the company so that they can pay their
employees and they didn't do that.
And as a result,
a lot of interest industries that we had
back then,
like,
uh,
we used to have great bosses,
for example,
we had that car industry small but still
relevant at the time.
And as a result,
they all closed down in the situation
was Getting worse and worse.
And now that wayne,
we eh carbon to be in the eu and despite
the things that were being told by the
media that oh my god,
the u is our home and if we live will
turn into North Korea.
It's fuckinG laughable.
And how am I supposed to take you
seriously after this?
So basically the problems that we have,
a pretty much,
eh,
have gone plus 10 right at the moment.
We joined the eu and the eurozone in
2001.
I think.
So when,
uh,
I guess it was about a year ago when the
financial crisis seemed to be at its
worst right before the eu came in and
bailed out again.
But you're saying this is a pretty
crappy situation,
but what was it like,
like when you couldn't go to the atm and
get money out,
didn't they stop money coming up?
Like what did that feel like for you and
for your family when it feels like the
system is collapsing?
It's difficult.
They found the fact that you have to
take only 60 euros per day.
The atm and yeah,
we kind of have to adjust that.
All right.
Listen,
we could talk about so much.
We went,
we went pretty heavy here.
Listen,
where's the best place for Slovakia in
athens?
Uh,
there are several restaurants we didn't
get by gyros,
know that,
but uh,
I can really tell it's entirely up to
you.
But one warning,
if you see that kind of like a lot of
olive oil avoided,
stay away from the gyros with a lot of
olive oil.
All right,
well
no,
they,
they're not really that they said at
least to me.
fair enough.
Alright.
It's about us.
It was a pleasure talking to you.
Thanks man.
All right.
I am on with joe from Egypt.
Can I call you joe or should I call you
the last pharaoh?
Yeah,
fine.
Joseph.
Joe is fine.
Let's try it.
Wouldn't be like a bit awkward.
So
yeah.
All right.
So for people that don't know you,
you're the only person we selected out
of the 20 people that I actually do know
of because I follow you on twitter and
you are a youtube or by the name of the
last pharaoh and you do really some
great videos talking about atheism and
secularism and being an ex muslim and
the regressive left.
All of this stuff.
Uh,
but before we get into that,
tell me your 31 in Egypt.
how is life in Egypt these days?
Well,
it's kind of okay.
I mean by look out when I,
when people ask me that question,
I always like to think you'd like to
give myself some hope to say at least
I'm not living in Afghanistan or Saudi
Arabia.
So you're not just,
yeah,
just be able to,
you know,
to function and actually like on a day
to day basis,
I really don't feel like that much of
it,
just like for other people,
other people are getting like bad,
but for me I maybe because I just have
thick skin or something,
I don't know,
I'm not really feeling that affected.
So yeaH.
So we don't have to go too much into the
politics because I want to really focus
on what you're doing.
But you know,
he was only,
what,
three,
four years ago that the arab spring
happened and you guys lived under
mubarak who was basically a dictator for
30 something years.
You then you had the muslim brotherhood
by,
by democratic elections for a year.
Then they get overthrown by the military
again.
And that's where you're at now.
Um,
yeah.
So two people there.
What,
how do they feel just about the whole
system?
Is there a feeling that democracy is
ever going to come back?
Do they want democracy to come back
because it didn't really work for that
year.
Like what's the feelinG there?
Well,
yeah,
to like differentiate between like two,
like glasses with people.
So we have like that majority of
egyptians,
like their normal everyday,
like dental people do.
I would say they're like,
I don't,
I'm not happy right now as,
as they should,
but they're like kind of okay with it.
Like what would look with the current
government,
they were not happy during the muslim
brotherhood even more,
even less happy than deal with under
mubarak.
So that,
that was like,
that was gonna work at all that the
whole thing.
So bonked the political class in Egypt,
which I happen to just saying that like
90 percent of them are idiots,
but uh,
yeah,
they're not happy with anything which I
think is,
do you have like this like kind of like
aggressive his jaw kind of a thing
happening like all the time and they're
not focusing on what's important.
So they're just make big deals about
nothing.
While it will not talking about people
going to jail for just saying like
normal,
like just stupid shit.
The sick people are going to jail for
making jokes about feeling like balloon
balloon condoms with air and handed them
out so they just send them to prison.
Some people just went to prison because
of the glue,
like sketch comedy on youtube or
something.
They sent them to prison.
So I think the most important thing
that,
that needs to change in Egypt,
not another gene,
not the economy economy,
and they're just doing what they can.
I mean the government,
they,
they have,
uh,
they have an interest to just do as bit
as best as they can.
What I really think is important is the
whole free speech and like the blasphemy
law,
the,
that
modesty laws,
these kinds of loads need to go because
the constitution actually doesn't allow
it.
Some people should just focus on that,
uh,
raising the money getting goes,
like laws in front of the parliament or
in front of even the constitutional
court.
Because the egyptian constitution,
if you read it and forget it from Egypt,
you really want to know that it's for me
because it's like 99 point nine percent
secular,
like really freedom of speech like has
its own article that's like totally
guaranteed,
no restrictions moment in invitations
under any circumstances.
So the fact that we have laws punishing
people because the insulted this guy or
the president or like some.
I don't know anyone,
it's unconstitutional.
It's like 100 percent unconstitutional.
Yeah.
So with all that in mind,
I mean,
where do you get the balls to do what
you do?
You're showing me your face right now.
I asked you before we started recording
if it was okay if we wanted to do
something different or whatever,
wear a mask or whatever,
but I mean you'd put your videos out
there with your.
You're,
you're incredibly brave and clear and
honest.
I mean,
okay.
Just I don't see.
Oh okay.
that's better.
Yeah.
I don't see it like that.
I just see it.
Like I said that before to a lot of
people are not doing the videos
anonymously to hide it.
Just like my,
you know,
my privacy kind of that I don't like
putting my face on camera all the time.
Yeah.
But I mean if I was living in America or
something,
I would still do the videos anonymously.
People seem to miss that point.
I said that all that I'm not hiding.
I just don't like putting my face on
camera.
I just don't like seeing myself on
So that's it.
I'm not.
And to me it's like I dunno,
it's like I'm tired.
I'm like city one,
but I feel like I'm 60.
I'm thought I'm not going to hide it.
I'm not going to censor myself anymore.
It's just like people seem to forget
that on a day to day basis I have to
pretend to be someone else,
like everyone around me.
Even when I'm getting ahead,
god I have to like agree with the guy
was cutting my hair that dealt with or
we have like a particularly hot summer
these days that the weather is like a
last thing and,
and you know,
we have to be thankful because some
people got it worse.
So I have to agree with that.
Like every single minute of every single
day.
So I'm not going to censor myself
online.
That's like,
was going to happen.
So you have to,
you have to thank all of that.
It's really hot but not hot or that
really hot.
Yeah.
So basically in every muslim country is
you have to be thankful because you're
not like the worst thing on earth.
So as long as there's one guy that's
worse than you,
you have to be thankful.
Oh,
that guy.
And that guy should like,
have a problem with god.
Seriously.
It can always,
we can always get worse.
I get it.
Alright.
So I want to talk a little bit about
your personal stuff.
So you are an atheist and you consider
yourself an ex muslim,
correct?
Yeah.
So you put these videos out there and
you have,
you have a real fan base.
It's awesome.
Uh,
what about in your own personal life?
They're like,
are you,
are you out to your friends and family?
Like how much can you talk about that
stuff?
Well,
look,
my friends and family,
like they know I'm not like religious.
That's what they know.
And they know that I'm kind of like,
you know,
I,
I just don't care about any annual that
they know that,
but they don't know that I'm like a
hundred percent atheist.
Actually,
the idea wouldn't even enter their
minds.
Even if I told them they would be like,
you know,
there's not,
the mind wouldn't be like cut because
the option's not on the table.
He didn't like Egypt during the muslim
countries.
It's not an option to be an atheist.
No one knew that.
No one told me that.
So if someone would have told me that
when I was six years old because I
always wasn't compliant with religion.
So if someone would've told me that,
like when I was young,
the idea I'm,
I might've made the switch a long time
ago,
but the idea wasn't even there.
So when did you make that switch?
When did you wake up?
Uh,
I think it was about three years ago at
some,
like a,
you know,
like I had like a major event happened
in my life.
So I had to stop because I was just gone
and I wasn't really paying attention.
but I never really was a muslim if you
really like
considered it a like what,
what,
how I was living.
I never really was.
I didn't even stop to think,
you know what,
maybe this is all bullshit.
I never stopped to say that to myself,
but when my life just stopped me,
like forcefully stop.
I hAd,
I had some time to like reflect and
think and just reach a conclusion that
it was just like right there.
But they never really even considered
it.
Yeah.
And did you jump on youtube right after
that?
Because the stuff that you do there is
really great.
And we'll put a link below so everyone
can find it.
This is it though,
isn't great.
I don't think it.
Yeah.
But I,
I think you're brave for having me.
Actually.
I'm brave.
I think you're backwards.
No,
no,
no.
Because like my videos are not like
advertiser friendly or something.
They don't really follow like cold,
like.
Yeah.
So.
So yeah,
I know.
What actually made me jump from unt was,
I know it's like a cliche at this point,
but actually it was the sam harris ben
affleck.
Think,
I mean,
it was like,
that was my awakening too,
so we're across the world.
Yeah.
It was like,
no,
no.
Someone needs like,
someone needs to have this guy's back
because he's like,
he's like taking old heat,
has seen something that's so obvious and
it's like ridiculous where people.
And actually not just the interview the
next day when cnn and all that,
that was like a shit show.
It was like,
can I say that?
You can say it,
go crazy.
You can say more than that can shit
show.
So yeah.
Uh,
yeah,
I had to like say something.
I actually uploaded two videos and
deleted them,
but then I uploaded the third one
because I wasn't really sure about the
other thing.
I was like,
okay,
if I get like 100 years on that,
I'll do a second one a and it just kept
going from there.
Think how awesome that is really.
I mean we live something like,
I don't know,
8,000
miles away from each other and that
moment,
that same night,
I mean that was my awakening.
I had had a little,
a little crack in my awakening before
that and,
and,
but we had that together that,
that is so cool.
So I'm thrilled to be talking to you.
Um,
but I,
I go ahead.
No,
no,
go ahead.
You're a good host to a so we only have,
we only have like another minute but
I'll do something else with you in the
future.
But uh,
just talk to me a little bit about the
regressives because you hate them as
much as I do this,
this regressive ideology.
So how does it affect you as a free
thinker and a secularist and an atheist
in Egypt?
How does their ideology harm you?
Your ability to live the way you want?
Well,
the basically shutting down any
conversation that could bleed to
anything because when you're talking
about like that.
Yeah,
that,
that there's no such thing that like,
that islam is just like any other
religion and like that they're ignoring
like the,
like the majority of muslims like
believe outside of us that day,
the United States or the uk or whatever,
that we are like living in horrible
conditions.
Do look at me,
I'm living like fantastically compared
to other people.
Even in Egypt,
no one bothers me.
I do whatever I want but some people
can't.
And when when you start seeing things
like that's like racist to just say that
we should like keep an eye on,
on some issues that are very important
and you should like,
you liberal.
That's the problem too.
You should,
you know,
you should actually leave everything and
just focus on that.
There are people getting murdered to
being gay or saying the wrong thing or
for listening the wrong kind of music or
you should do that.
You should champion that cause not just
for people living outside of year that's
just living inside you this and,
and the work travel because you know the
internet and all of that and don't even
get me started on this nonsense about
like feminism and islam.
Yeah.
We need like a whole other app.
You know what?
Here's what we do for real.
I'm going to do an hour with you because
this is just the beginning and I truly
am a fan of yours,
so we're going to do a full hour
together,
so I'm sorry we had to cut it short and
you know what I was,
I think I told you this,
but I was in Egypt back in 1997.
It feels like a lifetime ago.
Uh,
and I,
I would love to go back at some point so
maybe we can work that to.
But we liked your tour guide.
I'm going to show you the pediments,
all the cliches and other stuff too.
All right.
I am on with khrushchev from India.
Kusha.
You are number one.
You are first on the big rubin report
fan show.
How's it going in India today?
Now let's say I'm really happy that you
have me over.
Good.
It's really hard right now actually.
Yeah.
Through what's really hot for you guys.
Oh,
celsius.
Not fahrenheit.
So it's actually right now it's 35
degrees celsius.
And the humidity of 77 percent.
That'S pretty hot.
Oh man.
Are you.
Are you an air conditioning right now or
you just have a series of fans?
Air conditioning.
Yeah.
Very nice.
Alright,
well I'm super excited to talk to you
now.
I don't know.
We've got a lot of responses.
I don't know that all one point 2
billion with a b people in India
responded.
But we did get a ton of responses from
India about 100 people.
Uh,
so.
So you're the,
you're the lucky one out of 100.
So there was a lot of things that you
sent me that I thought were really,
really interesting.
Uh,
so first off,
and a few people in India talked about
this,
you mentioned just the general state of
freedom of expression in India right
now.
So can you tell me a little bit about
your concerns about the state of freedom
of expression?
So here's the thing,
I don't want to paint a very dangerous
scenario or something on that sort,
but you know,
as a skeptic,
I'm a skeptic myself.
So,
I mean,
in India we had some weird laws.
So I'll give you an example of a couple
of situations.
So it all starts with a,
a particular constitutional article or
two 95 eight.
So basically that article restricts any
criticism of religion.
So I'm not going to give the whole text
of the article to you because that will
just take away a lot of time.
But the article says that you cannot
hurt the sentiments of religious people
and here's the funny part.
So it's basically a blasphemy law anD
India is a 80 percent hindu country and
hinduism does not even have a concept of
blessed with me.
So I mean it's hilarious actually.
But the history of the law is that in
1926,
I think it was in 1926,
we had this,
a publisher who published a book called
the gila soon.
So it's award in hindi.
So dragila resume means a prophet
muhammad the casanova or the playboy.
So it basically spoke about the
marriages and the sex life of prophet
moment.
Now obviously muslims did not like her
at that time and there was a lot of
rioting.
This is in 1986.
So eventually the publisher was murdered
and the villagers,
because they didn't want to deal with
it,
they just came up with is blasphemy law
and we're just stuck with it now to
2016.
Hold on.
So if hindu hinduism has no blast for
me.
So it's really only being used one way.
It really sort of has nothing to do with
hinduism,
right?
Yeah,
it's not.
But the tragedy is that even hindus or
started using this law,
that's the tragedy.
See,
see,
I,
I might be a skeptic,
but I don't consider myself to be
outside the hindu pantheon because you
know,
we don't have that abrahamic problem
where,
you know,
18 are considered outside.
The abrahamic pantene.
Hinduism had a very old tradition of
atheism built in,
in itself.
It hurts me even more because I
considered myself to be a hindu and we
have this law and nobody talks about
her.
I'm in,
there have been rationalists who had to
live in the.
I'll give you an example.
There was a rationalist calls and allah,
I don't know his second name,
but I know his name so now.
So he basically went around in 2012 when
he was talking about how certain
miracles claimed by christians were not
real,
so they use this law and they've been
down on him and he had to leave India.
He stays in Finland now.
And that's really sad.
Recently there was a comedian,
kiko,
the.
He made fun of a guru.
So the followers of that guru,
they went after him again.
He had to apologize and I can give you
examples of various religions obviously.
I mean the highest amount of offense is
caused by a particular religion,
which nobody talks about.
Right.
I got it.
I got a lot of emails about that.
I think everyone knows which one you're
talking about.
So one of the things that you wrote that
I thought was really interesting you
said wanted to make the distinction
between tolerance and mutual respect.
And I really thought that was
fascinating because here in America at
least we talk about tolerance all the
time.
We have to tolerate everybody,
but in a way that's not a very lofty
thing.
Mutual respect is.
So can you explain that?
So basically,
it's not something that I've come up,
but it's a concept that was discussed
and uh,
you know,
basically it's a concept introduced by
indian american author called reggie
mulatto.
He wrote a book called being different
in 2011.
So what he basically talks about is
every time we have an interfaith
dialogue,
right?
So you have these interfaith dialogues
where everybody around the table test,
oh,
we tolerate all religions,
spoke about it in a very beautiful way.
so the,
you know,
he went around asking people,
so do you tolerate your spouse in your
house?
Do you tolerate someone when you're
having dinner with them?
So I have just basically taken this
concept being a skeptic.
Now I'm taking it to the next level and
I'm saying,
okay,
here I am.
I'm a skeptic.
I may not agree with some use of
hinduism.
I may not agree with a lot of views of
islam or christianity,
but very mutual respect comes in is I
don't need to tolerate you.
I need to respect you and you need to
give me that respect back in return.
That's when you have a dialogue
tolerances,
you're saying you suck,
but it's okay,
I'll let you be
right,
but I won't kill you.
Pretty much that's,
and this is again,
it stems from this exclusivist nature of
abrahamic religions.
See,
hindus don't have this problem and I'm
being very honest.
I mean I've never faced a hindu saying,
you know,
I'm going to come across a hindu says,
oh,
I'll tolerate.
You know,
hindus would be like,
okay,
you don't believe in god,
you do your own thing.
I'll do my own thing.
But you know,
it's not like one god,
one book,
one religion.
It's not that.
So does that make the state of atheists
in India much stronger?
Actually,
because I did get,
I would say probably half of the people
that emailed us from India said they
were atheists and didn't make it sound
like they were hiding per se.
Obviously you're doing this right now,
so if hinduism,
which is 80 percent of the religion in
India is sort of tolerant of atheism.
That's pretty fantastiC,
right?
Yeah,
it is.
See,
I like to classify indian atheism in
three parts,
so there are the hindu atheist started
the hindu dot skeptics.
I,
I call myself a skeptic,
so we,
we are not sure about some claims of
hinduism,
so I would say I'm skeptical to
reincarnation.
I'm skeptical to a few claims that the
gurus make,
but there are a lot of thIngs in
hinduism that are beautiful.
I mean I personally like the theory of
karma as a action and reaction.
I think a karma could be taken as an
action and reaction,
but then there are.
There's this new atheism in India,
I called them the marxist atheists.
So basically you have to understand the
political scenario,
India and especially the media.
You have the social sciences and the
humanities departments.
They keep churning out these marxist
state tests.
So when you got a lot of emails,
I wouldn't be surprised that you must
have gotten a lot of emails of those
marks.
The status will paint a very different
picture about hinduism to you.
And then I have the third category,
which is the one,
the ats.
So that peRson has not read anything,
so they just probably saw a video offer,
richard dawkins on youtube and they must
have gone,
okay,
I like this,
you know,
it's like that.
So I have three categorizations of
atheism in India that are mixed skeptic.
Yeah.
Well listen,
I feel like we just started and you're
my first person at a 20,
but our time is up already.
But I really,
I appreciate your support.
I appreciate you coming on and sharing
your thoughts and I have got to make it
out to India.
So when I do,
I'm going to look you up.
Yeah.
When you come to mumbai,
dinner's on me.
Done and done.
All right.
I am here with hannah in Texas in the
good old us of a had.
How are you?
I am amazing.
I'm doing well.
Uh,
texaS.
It feels like Texas is like a whole
other country in a way.
What's going on in Texas?
Well,
honestly I think that we are better than
North Carolina right now.
That's pretty good.
Yeah.
I mean like we get,
we get a lot of bad rap here.
um,
but at the same time when you actually
live here,
it really depends on where you live.
Like Texas is bigger than like France or
something,
right?
So I live close to dallas.
I'm not super close but about an hour
away from that.
And the closer you are to these major
cities,
the better it is,
but whenever you start getting out to
the rural areas it gets kind of hickish
but they're good people.
It's always like,
well intentioned,
good old boys sort of thing going on.
Alright.
Alright,
I'll go with that.
Well your submission was really great
because you gave me,
you gave me a lot to work with you.
So first off you are trans big deal,
but you are trans.
Um,
yes.
And I,
I put a little asterisk on that.
Um,
I am somebody who is very anti labels
and therE's a reason for this.
I'm not again,
special snowflakes stuff later,
but I don't know what I'm agreeing to.
Whenever I say yes,
I'm trans.
I mean like how far does that go?
That's always the big question.
Whenever you're saying,
are you a trans man,
trans woman,
transsexual,
transgender,
across,
where are the lines?
You know what I to if I say yes,
I am that,
but in a colloquial general
understanding at the very basic level me
back just kind of stopped at the side.
I think that's really interesting and
it's actUally kind of freeing because
you as the person that identifies
however you want to write it as if
you're making the point of saying,
well,
sometimes these are a little confusing
or don't quite get it right or all that.
Meanwhile,
meanwhile society is just obsessed with
these labels,
right?
Yeah.
It's,
I have been doing this for close to nine
years now.
The thing with the internet is that you
don't really know who is typing what.
So for the,
for the most part,
a lot of the trans stuff that comes out
and people doing that,
it's probably people just trying on a
persona or trying on an identity or
something like that.
it's usually teenagers.
Um,
and I think that we kind of take them a
little bit more seriously than we should
on a,
on a national hysteria type level.
Um,
but I don't necessarily see that there's
much wrong with it,
but it just let it be what it is instead
of making a big deal out of it.
If it's online,
like in person stuff,
like real tangible happenings,
that gets a little bit more attention or
should.
But whenever people online typing or
posting or whatever,
it's like it could be anybody.
Are you telling me that tumbler is not
real life?
Is that what you're telling me?
I know it'll blow your mind.
Wow.
You know,
you can be anything on the internet like
an attack helicopter.
That one's really popular now.
Is that a big one right now?
Identifying as an attack helicopter.
It's great.
So all right,
so let's,
let's back up a little bit.
So for someone that's watching this
right now,
wherever theY are,
are in the world that has never heard
from a trans person or the only trans
person that they know of is caitlyn
jenner.
Can you jusT tell me a little bit about
growing up?
When did you realize you were trans,
etc.
This is always very difficult
because everybody's going to have like a
similar overarching narrative,
but it's going to have its different
details.
I knew something was off as a child,
which is one of those common narratives,
but um,
I grew up southern baptist and being
raised that way,
it's very kind of closed off.
Everybody that wasn't southern baptist
was influenced by the devil,
but we moved around a lot and all that
sort of thing.
And just,
I don't know how to qualify myself.
Like we are kind of the only people it
seems nowadays where you have to explain
yourself,
rationalized to me why I should accept
that you are who you say you are,
right?
You guys are the ones at the moment,
but you know what,
that won't last forever for whatever
that's worth.
So it's one of those.
SeriouslY,
I wish I could give a definitive answer
like,
this is exactly how I know I can point
to these scientific studies.
This is exActly what happened.
I can't,
we don't,
we're not there yet when I can point is
that trans people have existed
throughout history and multiple
cultures.
This is not a new thing.
It is only new to the american west.
Um,
and what I mean by that is the modern
american west native tribes,
different allowances for different
genders and gender roles.
Sure.
So it's only new to the north american
west and I think that kinda goes back to
like a puritan european influence and
whatnot,
kind of scrounging all deviancy from,
uh,
the possibility of,
of human experience and I'm sure that
there were people back there and I'm
white european colonials or whatever
that were also trans but could not say
anything or risk of being hung or killed
or whatever.
Yeah.
So
yeah,
I'm curious,
um,
how much of your sort of just mental
energy and an ability to be a
functioning person is about just having
to explain yourself because that seems
more exhausting in a way than,
than dealing with something personal.
It is exhausting and it was exhausting.
I think a Lot of trans people go through
very similar faces and their transition.
When I first started,
I was a helper.
I was going to be there for my trans
sisters who were just starting also,
um,
I spent a lot of night sleepless.
I'm trying to keep people from killing
themselves,
um,
but also trying to educate and explain
and all this sort of thing.
And uh,
as time went on and I,
I got more passing privilege as we call
it,
that I didn't have as many people
stopping me and asking me,
um,
and I kind of developed sort of a,
a passive routine of like,
this is how I'm just going to interact
with people and just be super kind,
super sweet and all that sort of thing.
And there's that pressure that you
always have to be on your,
a game as a transwoman and around the
normal people or whatever.
Right?
Um,
and there's,
there's two camps on this.
There's the radical queers who are like,
we should not be trying to fit in.
We are unique in our own way and it's
beautiful and all this sort of thing.
And then there's the people who are
like,
well,
no I don't.
I kind of just want to fit in it.
It's difficult trying to navigate this
because it's very politicized.
Uh,
if you choose one side or the other or
you try to not pick a side,
nobody's going to like you and you end
up in your room all alone all the time.
Well,
is that,
is that one of the.
Is that one of the hardest things about
sort of being a,
not only being a minority in this
regard,
but like as I said,
trans issue seemed to be the minority of
the moment as you referenced before,
this issue with the bathrooms in North
Carolina.
Everything trans is know,
makes edge
and it makes all the news.
So do you feel that you're under a
microscope even in just your private
life with everything that you do?
He.
Yes.
And here's,
here's the thing,
I have been using the women's restroom
for eight years without any issue.
Now I'm scared because now,
I mean that's interesting.
Now people are looking,
now people are scrutinizing and whenever
governors or mayors or whoever it was in
North Carolina says,
women shouldn't spray people if they're
scared in the bathroom.
And a year,
a year ago,
I'm a girl with a n,
I'm going to get in trouble for saying
this genetic girl with the vagina
actually got pulled out of a restroom by
men because could you say,
a genetic vagina?
So,
so a female regularly cis gendered
female.
Cisgender.
So there's so many words on perform her
femininity well enough.
Got it.
Right.
Um,
so that,
that's a specific issue and it always
makes me wonder whenever things like
this happening,
like what else is going on?
Like what,
what are the real issues that are going
on right now whenever they put this
panic out here,
like we've been around all this time,
but just for now,
for some reason right now,
now we talk about this,
now we need to have this national
discussion.
What's the real issUe?
Like what's,
what's happening?
I'm the new cycle is pretty quick.
So I think this one,
hopefully we're shifted out of this one.
Yeah.
Um,
it's the process and everything,
I'm just saying this is blowing my mind.
So that's more of a specific issue and
in this like the trans experience is
hugely diverse,
as diverse as the queer experience and
you're getting like who do you define as
trans because if you go with the tumbler
versions or whatnot,
if you cross dress on halloween for
rocky horror picture show,
you qualify as trans now
congratulations.
Um,
and you can't really say no,
you don't qualify if you're in that
community because suddenly you're
removing somebody's identity and you're
going to get in trouble for that and all
that sort of thing.
So I'm just kinda like,
I need to accept the concept of
[inaudible].
I don't know if you're familiar with
that,
but.
No.
Yeah,
I quality as a term.
I'm kind of like,
I think so much that I'm an armchair
philosopher,
but quality was a,
a word that was coined that was to,
to describe the specific experience that
we each have.
So whenever you look at like a blue
wall,
you will have a certain range of
emotions and feelinGs and all that.
And I will have a supposedly different
one and that is quality so we can relate
that we're looking at a blue wall,
but whatever's invoked inside of us is
going to be different.
So that's kinda like the trans
experience in this.
The best I can do when it comes to
rationalizing it was like I just know
what I feel and I'm sorry that you can't
relate.
And again with the bathroom issue.
Oh my gosh.
Well listen,
I appreciate it.
Oh go ahead.
well I mean like I,
I appreciate people trying to relate to
the trans issues and like whenever they
think of the bathroom thing,
they're like why would I go to the
bathroom?
Or,
or why do I think people would go to the
bathroom first thing that comes to mind
while sexual assault or something.
Right.
And I'm like,
come on,
you should not get an address and go
into the bathroom then like a year
messed up.
There is one other thing that I wanted
to talk about that you mentioned in your
submission that I thought was really
interesting.
You brought up a phrase that I hadn't
heard before called constructed illusion
and you related this to having a male
and female voice
when you may use each one.
Can you tell me about that?
Um,
so this is what I'm.
people will call performing gender.
So I have developed this voice with
years of training.
It's still,
my voice is just exercised,
right?
my arms aren't exercised,
but um,
so I have a wider range.
So with this voice I get treated
different whenever I interact with
people because I'm not threatening with
this voice.
But if you're ready for this,
if I drop my voice,
I suddenly become a threats.
RiGht?
So I can switch between these two.
But that was the voice that's affected
by testosterone.
And anybody who heard that I am
immediately a different person.
There is no going back,
right?
The illusion is broken,
but how do they know that's just not
another one of my develop voices.
And this is kind of why I call it
constructed illusion because if it's
related to magic tricks,
performance magic,
you do mr [inaudible] and all that sort
of thing.
And it is a performance in a sense,
but in another sense it is me and it's
really hard to really unpack that in a
short amount of time.
But it's inter subjectivity with my
voice.
It was for me at first,
but eventually I kind of start feelinG
trapped by it because even though I've
exercised this place,
I'm still not capable of a full ranGe of
emotional expression using it.
Makes sense.
Right.
But the,
I assume that there's an evolution with
that,
right?
Like you'll,
you'll get there,
so to speak eventually,
but it takes a lot,
a lot,
a lot of practice.
So this,
this goes back into like passing
privilege and all that sort of thing.
So it was really nice talking to you and
I probably talk talking to you.
So ecstatic.
Alright,
I'm on with jason and brussels.
Jason,
has it gone?
Fantastic.
A pleasure to be on.
yeah.
Well,
uh,
I'm excited to talk to you.
So you are in brussels,
but originally from cypress.
So we're going to get this.
We're going to get to Cyprus in a minute
because nobody talks about Cyprus,
but it's a really interesting tiny
little country that very people know
about a,
but you're in brussels now,
obviously the last few months in
Belgium,
but especially in brussels have been
very tough.
So can you just start with that?
Well,
yeah,
I have to say it hasn't affected people
on a,
on a conscious level.
I mean you see people going about their
daily routine,
but it's definitely had a very malicious
sort of subconscious undertone,
particularly since the paris attacks.
Uh,
we've had a martial law on and off and
it's very concerning when you see four
armed soldiers outside mcdonalds and an
armored car outside your workplace.
Yeah.
So,
um,
yeah,
it's,
it's been very strange and the attacks
actually happened at a metro station
that I use quite frequently.
So when you see these changes,
you see more soldiers out there,
you see more security and all that kind
of stuff.
How does that change your general psyche
like that you're walking to work and
you're seeing this stuff?
It changes just sort of the day to day
right?
Well,
no,
you become accustomed to it actually,
but uh,
I mean it's,
it's very disturbing to see the military
deployed in a western capital,
uh,
I mean it's like the problem is truly
have become a global,
so there were a lot of reports after the
attacks in brussels that in parts of the
community that one of the attackers was
from,
and I guess they found him a couple of
weeks later that the community there was
knowingly hiding him were people talking
about that in Belgium.
It's sort of trickled it's way into
western media but not really.
And then it was kind of hard to tell
what was actually true.
Well,
I don't think that he's just a problem
that's isolated to Belgium.
I think in general,
um,
we don't see a members of the local
community where many of these suspects
from turning them in,
making a concerted effort with the
authority and it is something that we
have to try and deal with through better
integration policies.
yeah.
So how is the integration going,
I guess?
I guess to that point,
it's probably not going that great.
No,
no,
it's terrible.
I mean,
you have different communities that live
parallel lives,
uh,
which,
I mean,
they,
they exist occasionally in the physical
space because,
I mean,
you opened the physical spaces overlap
slightly,
but they just live in a different
reality.
Right?
So how much of That,
where do you place all the blame on
that?
Because this is one of the things that a
lot of people emailed us about was,
was this idea,
especially people in europe were saying
that a lot of the muslIm communities
aren't integrating properly and they see
some people were sort of blaming their
own governments.
Some people were blaming the,
uh,
the muslim communities.
It's,
my guess is that the truth is somewhere
in between.
What do you think?
Well,
I like to go from more abstractly and
say that the problem has been,
uh,
because of our social justice approach
or rather aggressive approach giving,
we've been giving rights to a
communities rather than two individuals.
And it's very arbitrary to,
to define a community in a certain way.
Uh,
and um,
and you know,
because the premise of our
individualized kind of rule of law has
been,
uh,
the rights should be given to
individuals and not to,
um,
you know,
what social justice people,
however,
social justice people decide to classify
people as.
So how much have those ideas?
Clearly you're,
you're speaking my language.
It's about the individual,
not the group.
Let's get away from this oppression,
olympics thing,
all of that stuff which we've talked
about so much here.
How much of that ideology is,
has taken hold in Belgium?
Well,
I'm,
I'm more qualified to talk about
specifically about how this is
manifested in the uk because I've been
doing a study on that.
So you've been,
you've been studying this in the uk
about a school system,
right?
System,
yeah.
Because in the,
uh,
in the british school system,
what you have is you have a third of
schools which are regardless,
which are faith schools that receive
public money,
uh,
because,
they have designated a religious
character.
And what we see here is that I believe
that the child's rights are being
infringed upon because,
uh,
basically because the child is
classified as,
as belonging to a particular community,
uh,
they get labeled by very arbitrary
criteria,
um,
and um,
and attend a faith schools just to
fulfill the aims of social justice.
And I think that this is a,
this is a very large structural problem.
It's a bizarrely backwards thing that we
do in the west.
I mean,
we do this in America with several
religions where the government funds
sort of faith based schools even though
we're totally secular society.
Well,
yes.
And um,
and you know,
shockingly,
in the uk,
the faith goals have a,
have a,
have an exemption from,
from even the equality act.
I mean it's written in the law that they
have an exemption from treating people
equally and employment and,
and admission.
And uh,
the problem is although the schools are
obliged to teach the national
curriculum,
they teach it through a religious lens.
So you might learn about many secular
subjects,
but then about other religions and
secularism and how to behave in a civic
society.
But if you also learned that the penalty
for apostasy is death and that the law
and that the law of god,
uh,
in the arEa above the,
the law of the state,
then you're less likely to want to
integrate and be part of the cohesive
society.
Yeah,
I mean,
to me that's,
that gets to the heart of the social
justice stuff because it seeps into the
education system.
Then you have a government that is
subsidizing basically religious teachinG
a suicide.
Yeah.
Alright.
So let's move away from that for a
little because I do want to talk about
Cyprus with you.
So nobody knows about cypress.
It is a tiny little island country.
You're from there.
Just tell me a little bit about your
history.
You don't have to give me the whole
history of cypress.
Uh,
but tell me a little bit.
I'll give you the,
the recent history that most,
uh,
significant now.
Yeah.
Uh,
yeah.
Well,
in 1974,
the turkish army occupied half of
cypress and the island has been divided
since then.
The turkish state installed a kind of
fag republic that's only recognized by
Turkey and Pakistan.
And,
uh,
have been ongoing attempts to resolve
the situation,
uh,
over the decades,
but,
um,
I feel that I'm not very optimistic
about the two sides coming through a
settlement because of the physical power
that Turkey is exerting.
I think whether Turkey withdraws or not,
it's mainly a subject of the trajectory
of turkish foreign policy and whether
it's in turkey's interest to leave.
and my hope is that because turkish
foreign policy has become increasingly
islamophobia and it's shifting away from
the foreign policy of the west,
that the west might slowly,
and I suppose there's a growing
relationship between Cyprus and Israel
and my hope is that the west eventually
aligns its foreign policy closer to
secularist entities throughout the
region,
like the kurds for example also.
Um,
and my hope is that that will will lead
to a better.
Um,
we'll,
we'll give cypress leverage in
negotiations because it will have the
backing from the west list.
So
yeah.
Well,
I promise you that I will talk about it
more because,
you know,
we've talked about the kurds here,
but as you said,
cypress is a sovereign nation,
a united nations member country.
And it's in full occupation since 1974.
So there's a lot.
Listen,
there's a lot more that we could talk
about unfortunately.
We got to move on.
I got a long day of interviews,
but it's been a pleasure talking to you.
All right.
I'm on with gel up in Canada.
Jill.
How are you?
I'm good,
thanks.
Well it's good to have you here now.
First off,
before we get into any of the issues you
emailed me about,
is it true that Canada is going to build
a wall to keep americans out regardless
of who wins our presidential election?
I've heard rumors,
yes.
Okay.
Rumors.
All right,
we're going to get that on the internet.
Okay.
So you sent me some really interesting
stuff that sort of touched on some of
the things that we talk about on the
show,
but then you really went in another with
it,
which
is why I wanted to have you on.
So one of the things you mentioned a is
that sort of the mental health anti
stigma campaigns that we see these days
are actually part of the regressive left
ideology.
Now I gave a lot of buzzwords there.
So can you unpack that for me a little
bit?
I think so.
Not very many people,
um,
agree with me on it.
Well,
let's see.
Let's see.
Well,
it's the same sort of victim mentality,
um,
except pretty much anyone can be a part
of it.
It seems almost like a club to be
mentally ill these days and a lot of
times it's,
ignores the real issues.
Like right now I'm in Canada,
we have a huge crisis with the first
nations communities,
like lots of youth are committing
suicide,
but of course the anti stigma campaigns
want to hijack this and make it about
illness.
But if you actually talk to these youth,
they say,
well,
we have no hope because there is no hope
here.
We have no jobs,
we have no library,
things like that.
Um,
so I think just the campaigns tend to
really stay away from the issues and
tend to put people again in the victim
role.
Yeah.
So you're sort of talking about two
things there.
So on one hand there's the feeling if
the economy is not good or their family
life isn't good or whatever it is,
it is sort of a reality in their life
versus these campaigns that in a weird
way because of this oppression olympics
that we've talked about,
kind of make it cool to say,
well this is wrong with me or this is
wrong with me or I have this or this or
that.
Correct.
Yeah.
There seems to be a bit of a hierarchy.
Like it's more cool to be like bipolar
then to be depressed and,
and they seem to be seeing except me
because I'm not like you.
Whereas we all know like the way towards
acceptance is to be,
well we're,
we're all human,
we're all the same.
But um,
they're really going for no because I'm
different and it's not my fault.
So sort of for people who don't have an
illness,
what does that mean?
If they're struggling that they
shouldn't be accepted.
So.
Right.
That's really kind of fascinating.
So someone who doesn't have a,
any,
any known condition,
so to speak in a weird way then then it
feels worse for them because they're
supposed to feel okay,
right?
Yeah.
And there's a lot of research showing
that the more we sort of give people
these information about these elements
to some more,
uh,
we create them in people,
because it's,
it's very much cultural and uh,
but they just have to get a brain scan
and people pay attention because they
think that science.
Yeah.
Do you guys have the,
all the crazy commercials that we have
in the states,
you know,
you turn on the tv,
especially any of the cable news shows
and all the commercials are for one
depression medicine or,
and you know,
there's
a cartoon cloud following somebody and
take this medication with this
medication and it makes everybody think
that they're depressed or somehow
defective.
Yeah.
I don't watch tv,
but uh,
I'm sure we did have those.
Your,
you're a wise woman.
Um,
so a lot of this though,
from what you wrote to me is very
personal for you because you're a
recovering addict yourself,
right?
Yeah,
so can you tell me a little bit about
that,
that either a,
you know,
what you were doing,
how you got out,
cetera.
You don't have to give me every bit of
personal stuff,
but
yeah.
Um,
I would say heroin,
I guess I still am a heroin addict.
Um,
man,
I don't know,
not much to say about that.
Yeah.
And,
and are you,
you're in full recovery or I guess it's,
it's a lifelong struggle I suppose.
Right?
Yeah.
Uh,
almost two years.
Wow.
So,
uh,
the other thing that you wanted to talk
about,
which of course is related to all this
is the war on drugs and you know,
this is something we talk about a lot in
America.
Um,
I'm not that familiar with the,
with the drug situation in Canada in
general.
Can you tell me a bit?
Um,
I probably don't follow politics as much
as they should.
I get,
I get too depressed,
but uh,
I have read a lot of bruce alexander's
work and vancouver,
which is where I'm from originally.
I has the worst addiction problem in the
world pretty much.
So he talks a lot about how
globalization has affected that and the
war on drugs pretty much focuses on the
drugs themselves as being evil.
And it's really not about the drugs.
I'm bruce alexander's work in the
seventies.
He pretty much disproved all other
notions of addiction,
but people are still held onto it.
Basically it was called rat park.
Um,
he gave some rats morphine water and of
course they used it up,
which is pretty much identical almost to
heroin,
but then he puts another group of rats
in like a bigger container where they
could socialize and they could play and
they had lots of room and those racks
wouldn't drink the morphine water even
when they had already forced them into
physical dependency.
Um,
so that to me is evidence against this
whole crazy notion that we should be
fighting drugs.
Canada is in probably in the same state
as America,
but we are certainly getting there.
Yeah.
But you guys do have some places with
vancouver,
for example,
where at least marijuana is legal,
right?
Um,
it's not legal.
I don't think,
uh,
we do have the safe sites,
but uh,
our conservative government or previous
conservative government tried really
hard to get rid of that.
Um hmm.
Interesting.
Well,
listen,
it's a,
it's fascinating to me because you took
sort of a theme,
uh,
related to,
you know,
political correctness and this
depression stuff and all that and
applied it to something that we haven't
talked about that much,
so I really appreciate your thoughts on
it.
All right,
I'm on with john.
Marco in Switzerland.
Has it going on in Switzerland right
now?
Eight,
eight a.
It's good.
It's evening and yeah,
I just waiting for your call here.
Yeah,
I got a guy with better hair than me.
This is very upsetting,
but we're gonna we're gonna do it
anyway.
All right.
So one of the things you wanted to talk
about was sort of coming out as an
atheist,
which I think is really interesting and
it's one of the things we've talked
about here that people feel this need to
make this proclamation.
So can you tell me a little bit about
your journey?
Uh,
yeah,
sure.
Um,
well I was born and raised in
Switzerland,
so it's not a religious country,
it's just like,
yeah.
Um,
I had some,
some religion classes in,
in primary and stuff,
but I wasn't ever really religious.
I'm catholic.
Was a catholic classes?
No,
it was evangelical.
Okay.
And um,
yeah,
then I went to sydney for exchange
semester,
um,
when I was like 18,
19,
and I stumbled upon this,
this,
uh,
debates have ken hamm against,
um,
yeah.
So,
and I would like to say the least.
I thought it was ridiculous that,
that some people would think that weight
like ken hemi was.
So basically for people that don't know,
he's the,
he's the guy that runs the board at the
biblical park somewhere in America and
he debated bill nye about evolution
versus creation.
Yeah,
yeah,
exactly.
Yeah.
So I was like a bit confused and,
and,
um,
yeah,
told my brother and he was a little bit
more into that and then she showed me
christopher hitchens and richard dawkins
and I felt it would be good english
lesson to,
to read those books.
Like god is not great.
And then,
so yeah,
I felt that I was,
I was talking to some people there
because I had connections to everywhere
in the world because like I had some
people from,
from sheila,
they're from Switzerland,
from Belgium,
from everywhere.
So what does donald me the most was this
guy from Switzerland actually who was
like while I believe in creationism and
I was like,
just,
it was a swiss guy like me.
What's,
what's thinking that,
that like noah's ark really was just,
it was just mind blowing for me.
Um,
so I started to,
to watch debates on youtube and stuff
and yeah,
when I came home I was like full blown
atheist.
It sounds to me that you deal with
exactly what most atheists deal with,
which is that it's not actually that big
of a deal,
but you feel like you have to sort of
say it because otherwise the world just
thinks you believe something that you
don't.
Yeah.
Right,
right.
It's like that.
And like when I,
when I discovered this,
all of this,
I was,
I wasn't a little bit more militant.
I don't know how to say like,
sure.
I thought people who believe this stuff
will be lazy or stupid or not really
stupid but like ignorant and kind of
weird.
So I got a little bit out of that.
I let them have their beliefs and
whatever.
Um.
Yeah.
But I need,
I feel need to tell that I don't believe
that.
Yeah.
Well,
it's funny because I always say to me,
I don't care what you believe as long as
you're not trying to chop my head off or
making me believe anything else,
then you go ahead and believe whatever
you want,
you know?
Um.
All right.
So one of the things that you wrote in
that you want to talk about that I
thought was really interesting was that
you want to talk about the difference
between the us constitution and the
swiss constitution and that basically
you think that we're a.
Don't worry about the hair,
that,
that we,
that we are sort of obsessed with never
changing our constitution,
but you guys actually change your
constitution pretty frequently,
right?
Yeah,
it was.
It wasn't like a debate about gun
regulation under the second amendment
United States,
and I thought to myself lIke,
why wouldn't they allow to change that
like inside oldest lobbying and stuff
from the nra,
a gallup poll that like 55 percent of
the american people are for,
I'm more strict can regulation.
So I looked into it a little bit more
and what I found was,
was pretty astonishing to me.
I've always thought like,
uh,
the american constitution is kinda,
it's kinda,
um,
static and,
and just for 230 years it was almost a
safe and swiss constitution as you may
know,
we have referendums like four times a
year where people just sending some
ideas and we vote on it.
And thiS is like changing the
constitution every time.
Wait,
did you say you guys do that four times
a year?
Yeah,
man,
that's a lot.
And people show up and vote four times a
year and actually change the
constitution that often.
Yeah.
Yeah,
it is.
Well,
we had like 50,
55 percent of the people at both.
Um,
the rest is just like,
yeah,
well do whatever you want.
And uh,
yeah,
but we won't like for 12 or 12 to 15
different referendum each year in force
steps.
Yeah.
So.
all right.
So have you seen any gimme gimme like
one good example of that,
like something that you guys have
changed for the better and one time that
maybe it didn't work if you can think of
something?
Yeah,
sure.
TwO thousand and 10.
I think it was um,
like the,
the far right party of Switzerland,
the svp proposed that we should ban
minarets,
like the towers on the mosques of the.
Yeah.
So,
and it was accepted by the people.
So now we have in our constitution our
article like 72 that it's prohibited to
build minerals like when we have like
two little ends.
So it was like no issue at all.
Right.
So it wasn't really a problem but the
far right grabbed it.
Yeah.
Yeah,
it was just like sinophobia,
populistic and.
Yeah.
And the good thing we accepted,
I really need to finish,
but it's like most things are good that
they're not accepted,
that we have some,
some,
like all these proposals are,
are either far right or far left like a.
Yeah,
like minimum wages and I mean that's
kind of okay.
But minimum wages were like set to $22
per hour and that's just ridiculous
high.
I mean,
who would pay that?
right?
So does that ultimately hurt the swiss
economy?
I mean the businesses then leave
Switzerland because it sounds like
Switzerland and we always think of it
as,
oh,
they have so much money.
Everybody's so happy.
It's so great.
Yeah.
No,
I,
I think so.
Yeah.
what I'm,
I'm not an economist,
but from what I've heard and what I've
read,
I think it will really hurt the country
as,
as a,
as a financial spot and,
and yeah.
And also,
yeah.
So the other thIng that you wanted to
talk about,
which is one of the things that almost
everyone in europe,
especially his wanted to talk to me
about is the refugee situation and
political correctness.
Uh,
so I'll let you go from there.
Yeah.
So um,
refugee crisis in,
in,
in Switzerland itself.
I mean I'm not that I'm on top of like,
like the whole situation.
I know where you stand on the balcony
stuff.
Don't worry.
I'm not going to quiz you on everything.
We're just,
we're just getting your opinion.
Okay.
So yeah,
I'm,
I'm basically for a like letting
refugees in like,
I mean we're all humans.
We should,
we should get along with each other and
help each other.
That's like human humanitarian aspect of
it.
But like the left is,
is pushing like these,
these ideas or these reasons to let them
in a like for example,
when when someone says just like
something a little bit,
I don't know,
let's say a controversial about refugees
and,
and yeah,
and what they're doing.
It's just like it Down and then you
cannot talk probably about,
about what the issue is with the
refugees that come in.
I mean I'm all for letting them in but
we have to talk about the issues that
are coming through us with this and
yeah,
they're just saying that or.
Yeah,
saying no,
there are no problems at all with this
or like maybe a little bit financial but
nothing really cultural or.
Yeah,
listen,
that's exactly why I'm talking about on
the show because we got to have these
conversations.
Listen,
that was quick,
but it was a pleasure talking to you and
thank you.
All right.
I'm on with adam in Sweden.
Adam,
has it gone?
It's going just fine.
Actually a great reporter to this.
Cool.
Well me too.
Uh,
so,
you know,
I've mentioned a lot about Sweden and
just recently I had a tino sign and
dodgy on the show who's an economist
from Sweden and one of the few people
that will talk about the political
correct situation and sort of this
regressive ideology that seems to have
taken hold in Sweden.
And I got a Lot of messages from Sweden
talking about that.
Uh,
and you were the one we went with.
So we expect you to represent your,
your whole country.
Here we go.
Oh boy.
I'm the most honest swedish.
We could find a good representation
there.
Well,
as you know,
I believe that it's about the
individual,
not about the,
the bigger group.
So let's start with that.
So one of the things you wanted to talk
about was that the political correct,
this seeping ideology and what it's
doing to society in Sweden.
So let's start with that.
Well,
uh,
I've been doing explain this because
it's,
it's fairly hard really,
since you need so much context for it
and we have so little time for it.
Yes,
we'll do the best you can.
I'll just save it.
It goes back at least a hundred years.
Started with the socialism and
everything like that in Sweden.
I'm,
but in the modern era at least since the
seventies.
Um,
Sweden was a hotbed for very radical
leftism in the seventies.
Um,
we even had,
um,
left this terrorist and everything like
that in the Sweden that occupied and the
east and the west german and Scott West,
german embassy.
And so it has a long tradition,
but the biggest things I actually want
to explain what this,
that explains how Sweden works today is
two terms and I think I've translated
them reasonably.
One is called the opinion corridor and I
think that's kind of self explanatory,
but I'll give an explanation that it's,
um,
that is in Sweden.
There's a very narrow corridor of
opinions.
We're allowed to have it arrest.
Well,
if you have only opinion outside of
that,
like me,
you're a nazi,
you're a racist,
you're big attend,
you know,
you're all of that
nazi or racist or bigoted.
Let's just get that out.
I'm neither of those.
I may be very arian,
but I'm not a nazi.
And,
and events opinion corridor for my
entire lifetime has just been narrowing
and,
and I would definitely say that it
narrowed its most when obama became a
president.
Really?
Yeah.
I would say in Sweden,
The last I'd say two decades I guess has
tried to emulate America and all its
worst parts.
And so we always had this opinion
corridor,
but then we saw how you guys started
going with the political correctness
part and then it just went worse.
So,
and
yeah,
I think that explains that part.
Then we also have another term that we
didn't advance,
but a swedish political commentator in
the seventies put two coin very well is
called veal hellman move battery.
And I would recommend reading up about
him because he will give a lot of
contexts that are bullshit that's going
on today.
Um,
and I think I'll try to pronounce this
demo creatorship he called it,
um,
combination of the word democracy and
dictatorship right now that works
essentially in that we have a formal
democracy,
um,
but on the best of the,
of the cultural force that our
government represents,
um,
we haven't enforced dictatorship of
sorts in the form of the cultural on
the,
in Sweden that know has its expression
in the,
uh,
in the opinion corridor,
right?
So what you're talking about basically
is as we,
we've used this phrase,
the oppression olympics,
you guys are really big on this,
that depending on who you are and where
you're from and your religion and your
skin color,
we really put you in this pecking order,
right?
Absolutely.
And you were baSically,
you were very much a home,
a home homogenous society.
And now that's really changing,
so the pecking order starts getting you
back.
We were a very homogenous society on
film until at least the nineties.
That's when the balkan wars erupted on
the other genocide.
And I'm doing that and we got a lot of
refugees from that.
Um,
they've Integrated mostly.
well,
we didn't really get the problems until
we have the very large immigration from
the middle east.
Uh,
it's easier to integrate a european
culture than a completely foreign
culture from an entire different parts
of the world with different cultural
context and all of that.
Um,
but I'm sayinG that would label you are
racist,
right?
Absolutely right.
I'm definitely a racist for sayinG that.
Um,
so,
so the problem is because that's outside
of the opinion courtyard,
we can talk openly about it and that's
cost all a lot of issues.
And
yEah.
So that leads,
that leads directly to the other thing
that you want to talk about,
especially at.
Exactly.
I mean,
yeah,
it leads to the other thing you want to
talk about,
which is the rise of the right in
Sweden,
which is a new phenomenon.
So can you lay that out?
Um,
yeah,
it's,
it's a new phenomenon because in Sweden
the left has essentially ruled as post
world war two,
uh,
for 60 years we had one party dominant
in our,
what's it called?
And parliament for 60 years we had the
social democrats completely dominant in
the parliament.
Uh,
only one the interruption for four
years.
And that's kind of when I look about it,
I'm a student of history so I can see
the negative side of it is absolutely
insane.
Does he just have one party that they
did achieve some pretty good things.
The things we called full kemeten to
Sweden or welfare states,
they did achieve that,
but they also dismantled it and so,
but the right has risen because we can't
speak about these things and they are
the only ones that had the balls to
speak about it because,
well,
the extreme part world or the nazis,
the less extreme but didn't really care
to be compared that they were compared
with the nazis.
So they just talked about it.
And now the only way to talk about this
is to dedicate yourself to being on the
far right,
essentIally.
Yeah.
So we see this happening in America
right now and that's why I've been
talking about it because I see all of
you guys,
not just in Sweden but all over europe.
I see this happening and I'm trying to
help that not happen here.
So what does that do for a person?
Like you have a person that is not a
nazi and is not a racist and yet you see
a problem with society and only one
group talking about it.
where does,
where does that leave you?
Completely alone,
essentIally.
um,
because the left.
Well they think I'm the great satan
there.
Right?
Well I'm also the great satan for them
because,
well,
you know,
I kind of think that brown people or
people to and jobs are done like people
and that's not right according to the
four,
right?
Yeah,
I mean I consider myself an ideological
ideologically independent because I
consider ideologies to be secular
religions.
Um,
so I,
I shy away from those things.
So it's very hard.
And being of my camp in Sweden,
which is,
you know,
liberal essentially,
that's the whole purpose of this show
and I almost everyone that I'm talking
today talking with today over all over
the world,
I mean this is what it's all about.
So just to end this real quick though,
because we got to go,
you're starting your own youtube
channel,
right?
To get these ideas across.
So where can we send people?
Uh,
the youtube channel has been slow.
I ended up taking because I've been
busy.
I'm a college student so.
Um,
but look for the thought criminals
channel in the near future.
Alright,
I'm on with michael in Colorado.
Michael,
how are you?
Hi dave.
I'm good.
Good to see you.
Yeah,
good to see you.
So I have to tell you,
we picked 20 people at a 1200 and I hope
you take thIs the right way.
You are the elder statesmen of the
group.
Oh boy.
Not to add any extra pressure.
Okay,
well that'll give me a beer at the local
bar.
So that's good.
Absolutely.
So first off,
you had a really interesting history.
That's one of the reasons why I wanted
to talk to you.
Uh,
and you were in the navy,
so first off,
tell me when you served,
where you served.
Um,
I was in the navy.
I joined and when I was 18 out of high
school,
uh,
went in,
in 1961.
Uh,
put that in context.
Let's see.
President kennedy announced the apollo
program.
A west side story came out and our
president,
barack obama was born when he was in
diapers.
I was in bootcamp and I served eight
years,
got out In 1969 to go to college.
Uh,
san diego.
I was on a guided missile destroyer of
all over the pacific for awhile,
came back,
got involved and the polaris submarine
program and I was stationed in Spain for
a couple years and then at charleston
for a couple of years working on some
high tech,
you know,
secret stuff and uh,
said adios to that.
And uh,
went to school on the gi bill,
took a degree in anthropology and pretty
much minored in history.
And then life going on.
Then life went on.
When you look back at that part of your
life to serve as part of your life,
do you think of it fondly?
Do you,
uh,
do you miss it?
Anything like that?
I do think of it finally,
you know,
distance,
mate does make the mind grow a little
bit more accommodating I think.
But all,
it was really good for me.
How it had no idea what I wanted to do
when I was 18 years old.
My friends,
many of them are going off to college,
but I knew I wasn't really ready for
that somehow.
Um,
it was good for me in a lot of ways.
It helped me to grow up,
uh,
gave me some responsibility now that I
can handle that gave me the equivalent
of a masters degree in electrical
engineering,
which was a big help.
But,
uh,
when I got out I abandoned engineering
and went directly into anthropology
because eight years of engineering is
pretty,
uh,
is enough.
But I'm pretty sure if my notes serve me
correct that in 1964 before you went to
anthropologie,
you built a computer.
Well,
uh,
Built and more,
more to the poInt I programmed my first
digital computer because when I got into
the polaris program that all the systems
on the boats,
these are intercontinental ballistic
missile systems are run by computers,
uh,
in 1964,
those computers,
we're probably not quite as powerful as
the iphone,
but I was very fascinated by computers
still still am.
Uh,
and as part of my training,
we put together a little block system of
computers,
have a digital computer and learn how to
do the basic programming.
It was all what we call machine
language.
It was all ones and zeros.
And then we went to the lab and we
started programming where you're going
on the big guys.
Nineteen 64.
So that was my introduction to digital
computer.
Yeah.
So that's so cool.
So 1964,
you're working on the very beginnings of
a,
of digital computers.
And he said,
oh,
the zeroes and ones.
Did you ever.
Do you remember ever having the glimpse
of what that could become?
Did you ever think you could be walking
around with this thing in your pocket
that would be exponentially more
powerful than everything you were
working on at the moment?
I don't.
I don't think anybody did at the time
because it was the beginning of solid
state to solid state years.
These things are really big.
Uh,
they,
they work,
they were in cabinets,
did,
was open to et cetera.
uh,
I remember when the personal computer,
they all chair those dose came out,
you know,
it was pretty neat.
You can have one at home,
but hell,
you know,
digital or ellie lcd watches were the
big thing back then.
And,
and Texas instruments calculators.
Nobody really thought that we'd be able
to have an iphone and communicate face
to face dick tracy,
like things when I was growing up,
the copies we,
you know,
we thought that would be pretty cool,
but whoever thought that the,
the advances will be that fast.
Yeah.
I remember being at a friend's house.
He's probably when I was six on a Texas
instruments computer playing a.
They had their own version of pac man.
It was like they're ripped off version
of pac man.
I thought it was the coolest thing ever.
Yeah,
yeah.
Well,
you know,
there was a book called future shock.
You're probably familiar with years ago
in which alvin toffler predicted at
progress would be so fast that by the
time you began to get a little bit
comfortable,
the next thing will come along and you'd
be a little bit in shock and you're
dealing with that.
The next thing will come to.
The next thing would come and I think
that's pretty much where we're at right
now.
It does seem like that,
that the second we get okay with a
little bit of the technology or just
some another app comes out the second
year.
Okay,
with one and then now this one does
something else and you forget that.
IT's really.
It's fascinating.
It is in the.
You know,
what I find kind of disheartening is a
lot of people.
One of the things I do here is I have on
the library board or if I helped some of
the older retirees here and try to deal
with their ipad and their iphones and
god help them,
their windows,
computers,
et cetera.
That must be a trial
in patients.
It's tough.
Can you deal,
can I give you.
Can I give my mom your number?
You can.
Okay,
good.
Not a problem.
Um,
but you know,
I liked a lot of the older people are
now understanding that this is actually
a device that can be used for things
like we're doing here and for making
contact with other people and spreading
ideas and getting your ideas out so and
so you become easier to use.
You know,
the human sense.
People are going to look past the
technology now.
I have a neighbor who's,
she's 20 years older than me.
Alright.
So she's 93 years old.
She has an ipad,
she has her,
your email and little google things and
all of that with her ipad.
And she's quite quite familiar with it.
It's sort of magic to her,
but she knows how to use it so it puts
her in touch.
That's really.
That's pretty cool.
All right.
Let's shift topics altogether because
you gave me a blind submission.
You,
you are an atheist.
Were you always an atheist?
When did you decide you are an atheist?
You were an atheist before.
It was cool.
Now it's cool.
Yeah.
Well,
it's a template that is still not cool.
I can point it to.
We have five churches and for real
estate offices in a town of 800.
So think about that for a bit.
So you're,
you're a real minority.
You're a minority and a minority right
there.
Yeah.
Yeah,
I am.
Especially here.
I remember I was thinking about that and
I remember when I was probably five or
six and we were living with my
grandmother going to church sunday
mornings,
sunday night,
wednesday night methodist church,
little north Texas town,
sitting in sunday school looking out the
window at the tree and the swing.
And so I'm thinking,
god,
I'd rather be eating place.
Um,
I think probably realistically about the
time I figured out santa wasn't real.
I had the same kind of questions are
about the stories I'd been,
I'd been taught.
So for about as long as I can remember,
I guess.
Yeah.
So one of the other things you mentioned
is that you're,
you're sort of fascinated by how a
christians and and just religious people
in general are often deceived by their
sources.
So it's not even necessarily the source
itself,
right?
It's not necessarily the book itself,
but it's sort of the messengers that are
the deceivers am I getting what you said
correctly?
I think it's both those things,
um,
you know,
if you look at abrahamic religions
today,
they don't have what we consider to be
basic hardcore evidence for their
claims.
The only thing they have a for a source
or books that stem out of oral
traditions that stem out in ancient
manuscripts that had been copied and
recopied and copied and changed and
different.
So I think there's a problem because the
people who are there pastors and who are
their priest and go to divinity school,
they understand the history of their
religion,
they know the questions involved,
they know the contradictions,
they know that a lot of this is really
false,
but they don't tell that to their
congregations.
So the people who hear this really have
no independent way of judging whether
this is real or not.
So if I have a book,
somebody giving me a book and says,
look,
this is reality.
I have some questions.
well where it come from,
what does it say?
How do we know?
What it says is true,
etc.
So digging back into those sources and
being able to come up with what we think
are historically realistic stories about
all of this helps people to be a little
bit more critical and judge the things
that they just take on faith.
Yeah.
So one of the things when I've talked to
other atheists,
and when I talk about atheism in
general,
one of the questions I get is people
say,
well,
how do you have a moral center?
Then?
How were you able to have a code that
you live by without religion?
I think you're laughing already.
sorta gave away your answer,
but tell me how have you.
How have,
what have you based your moral center
on?
What do I base my moral center on?
Well,
like I tell you know,
we have two adopted kids there.
They're adults these days and they're
doing quite well and one of the reasons
that they're doing well is because they
know what's right and what's not right.
You have this.
I think humans have this inherent
ability to to understand that the right
way to act,
for example,
is the way you act when nobody is
watching you.
You come out of this feeling of
compassion for other people.
You come out of this feeling of being
able to help other people and to be
basically a good person.
I mean sociopath's aside are normally
constructed human being,
you know,
I feel that you understand this.
I mean the greeks,
I understood it,
the romans understood it.
The plains indians understood it,
right?
They,
they are all allied to different
religious system,
so it's not an.
It's not something out of a religious
tradition or a book that says follow
these rules.
I mean,
you know,
it's wrong if you kill somebody in
murder,
for example,
that's just human basic wrong.
And I don't think it takes an ancient
book and dictates from when the guy in
the sky to say no,
do this and you're in trouble.
Yeah.
And if it does,
there's probably a bigger problem.
There's a bigger problem,
a bigger problem.
All right?
So,
uh,
unfortunately have to wrap it up but let
people know.
Uh,
so you're working on a book.
Correct.
And you have a website.
So where,
where can we send people?
You can send people.
I have a book.
It's already I self published it on
amazon.
The key fragments and it's about the
sex.
It's About basically what we've been
talking about.
Great.
It's digging back into the sources and
to finding out what we're going to segue
into secular situation.
What happened is a novel characters and
action.
You can go to the queue fragments.com.
Uh,
it's out there.
Links are out there.
I podcasted every chapter is a podcast
that I read,
so I just like people to read it,
enjoy the tail and think about the
message that underlies this,
right,
that all of these myths and everything
may have come from some particular
historical actors and people,
but they're not necessarily what people
are trying to get us to believe today.
Yeah.
Well I love that message and I love
chatting with you,
so thank you so much.
Appreciate it.
Alright,
thank you.
Have a great night and thank you for
your program.
All right,
I'm on with brandon and Ireland.
Brendan,
how's it going?
I'm doing well.
I feel like you could be my irish
cousin.
We are dressed exactly the same
apparently.
Actually my brother in law is half irish
and his name is brendan.
So there you go.
Okay,
cool.
Oh god,
um,
I probably should know that I'm going to
have to get back to you on that one.
Oh no.
Oh,
you already got me in trouble.
I think he's from near the local pub.
The pub to pub everybody at.
Alright.
So what,
what's going on these days in Ireland?
We don't hear much about Ireland in the
news.
How's it going over there?
You won't heAr much about us,
but we just had a new government forms
10 weeks after her election.
Miraculously.
No fan does.
There's a lot of discussion kind of.
And we have,
we have water charges were brought in
and that's been discussed a lot.
Um,
the,
the fire life doesn't end the socialist
parties.
They're not very happy with it.
Neither any really apart from the
parties and governments.
And there's discussion over repeating
our eighth amendment,
which is basically stipulates stopped.
Abortion is legal and artists and
obviously in the google phones we,
um,
last year we legalized marriage for
homosexuals,
which is fantastic.
Uh,
I wasn't in the country,
I was,
I was actually abroad in China for the
year,
um,
you know,
if you're irish abroad,
which I was,
I wasn't too happy and I couldn't go
was,
that was brilliant.
Wait,
let's pause there for a second.
So that's really interesting.
So you guys voted for legalizing gay
marriage,
which is obviously very great and a very
liberal,
progressive concept.
And then at the same time,
you're telling me that they're voting on
possibly repealing a law that would,
uh,
that allows abortion.
No,
no.
Oh,
so abortion is abortion coMpletely
illegal?
Yeah,
it's illegal.
Wow.
So,
um,
I need to do prp.
I assume people are having illegal
abortions because people have them,
whether it's legal or not.
Right.
Generally heading over to england.
Wow.
So you.
So do you think the law is going to
pass?
Uh,
I would say there was a savior died last
year.
There was unsafe.
And when opposition from perhaps with
charities and stuff against,
um,
against gay marriage,
no one really cares
are the churches.
I mean,
are they losing their power quickly?
How,
how much power do they actually hold
over politics these days?
You don't get too many people's onto my
house and they don't take it seriously.
And most of our is very,
you know,
with regards to say homosexuality or
whatever.
Generally as a country we're generally
quite alright with it would require that
our country basically like,
as long as you don't annoy me,
I don't really care what you do.
You know what I mean?
That's my personal ideology to
perfect.
Yeah.
I need to get entirely the obviously.
So you're studying politics,
right?
Yeah.
What got you interested in politics?
Uh,
I can't really remember.
I think I just really wanted a,
I don't know,
maybe maybe it was probably the
elevation with that new understanding
african children and stuff.
And you want to be like,
oh,
I'd love to help someone like that.
I'm just kind of grill and grill was
very interested in wars and I did,
I did a module last semester which was
ethnic conflict was that little of
monsters in the conflict doesn't matter.
So it's a lot of work in the united
nation to my thought and a conflict
resolution.
I've actually my team final exam for the
whole,
my whole undergraduate artS began,
so I'll be doing on saturday.
Nice.
Well thanks for taking some time then.
So how.
No problem.
So one of the things that you wanted to
talk to me about is one of the things
that pretty much everybody wanted to
talk about,
which is political correctness and how
it's,
how it's seeping into society.
So what's going on on that front in
Ireland?
um,
I think,
I think a lot of the stuff you see,
ideas of racism and stuff are imported
from America.
We all think,
oh,
he probleMs with race in America is a
very specific problem with racing.
You know what I mean?
And we think,
oh my god,
you're racist towards black people.
Got,
we never had that because,
you know,
we don't even our own country for nike,
nike for years,
you know,
25 years,
right.
Um,
we'll get,
we'll get people is generally higher
lefty for people in the,
on the social spectrum.
I'm not saying you,
you don't have to social stuff seat to
be ridiculous,
you know,
as,
um,
as marginal as to saying,
you know,
regressive left and off and you get
that.
We had that.
She was dealing with the german group
together to heat up.
They had a protest here.
It was like a hundred people,
300 people.
So
yeah.
So it's not really picking up steam
there.
Well,
this particular incident,
they were chased down the street by,
by a counter protestors to which we were
like,
I,
I totally disagree with that reads.
They're racist,
they're fascist,
whatever,
but up behind themselves.
But I think in art and we're doing okay
and when you look,
we see stuff or having an american law
walking by it
for everything that's going on here.
I'm wondering,
wondering about some of it myself.
Don't worry.
I,
I think we're okay,
but I mean when it comes to,
when it comes to terrorist attacks,
I'm criticizing islam.
You do get some really known.
Is onsite is the use of islam in a
violent way?
Use of anything.
What?
I mentioned the underclass and hoodie
when he looks.
Yeah,
that's been one of the through lines
here because we're just talking about
ideas and you mentioned an idea and you
get some funny looks in class.
Yeah.
But no,
no one is known as shutting me down.
Naming this safe space,
which is progress.
So you don't have.
You guys don't have safe spaces and
trigger warnings?
No.
If he smiled or university and they're
too small,
I've been.
Oh,
it hasn't caught on yet.
I think it's a combo.
Maybe have small universities and a lot
of beer.
Would that be fair to say?
No,
I think it's not showing up the class
because of the period before.
There you go.
Well listen,
it was,
it was a pleasure talking to you and if
you have any other fashion
recommendations,
let me know.
All right.
I am on with brianna in Japan.
Brianna,
how are ya?
Good,
how are you?
I'm doing well.
So according to my notes here,
you are in Japan via Tennessee.
How many people can say that?
Uh,
not very many.
So from personal experience they
probably don't even know to see is here
99 percent of the time.
So yeah.
So tell me,
imagine,
tell me a little bit about that.
So do you grew up in Tennessee and when
did you move to Japan?
What are you doing there?
What's going on?
Yeah,
so I grew up in Tennessee.
I was there for 18 years of my life
until I moved to philadelphia for
college and I've been in Japan for the
past six months now,
or study abroad.
I'll be here a bit longer and let's see,
in Japan they know what the Tennessee
waltz is and that's about it.
I don't even know what that song is.
I figured out about it when I was here.
It's an oldie,
I think their knowledGe of the states.
Yeah.
So what,
so,
so six months in Japan,
how have you been having major culture
shock?
What do you like?
What don't you like?
Has it gone?
Hm.
It has been pretty good so far.
The culture shock isn't as bad as I
thought it would be.
No,
it's pretty globalized world at this
point.
So you know what Japan is like
difference wise.
So it's been pretty good so far the
biggest difference has been the academic
system.
So it's pretty fundamentally different
from american conceptions of education.
Yeah.
So that's one of the things.
And that's one of the things that you
had written in that you wanted to talk
about a little bit about academia and
the difference between America and
Japan.
So let's,
uh,
let's do that.
Right?
So it's essentially been really
refreshinG being here because a lot of
them more and knowing aspects of
american academia are not present here
at the moment.
They might be later on in the future.
Right.
So like what for example,
so like the big issue with academia
right now,
as you can imagine is the ideological
like constraints placed on lots of
students there.
But college in Japan is not a very
ideological place.
Like the classroom is a sacred
environment.
You do not talk about ideological things
there.
So it's pretty much not an issue which
has been really good for me because
that's one of the reasons I wanted to
come to Japan to avoid that because my
college is very stereotypical,
very liberal and very free speech sensor
should be in lots of ways.
Sure.
And a lot of the people that I've been
talking to today are mentioning things
like that and we,
we know about all this stuff.
So in Japan,
is there a drawback to having sorta of
no ideology in the classroom?
Like is there any kind of drawbacks to
just sort of straight information?
There is a bit of a drawback.
Japan's academic structure has its own
issues that I could complain about all
day.
We only have eight minutes.
I know compared to the issues with
America right now.
I could deal with theM way more because
that's essentially just me saying why do
I have to respect the teacher all the
time?
I'm american,
I don't respect people.
So that's really the main issue.
But like information being presented
here just so straightforwardly really
does seem to help like nip the
ideological issues in the bud there
because that's not something teachers
are supposed to be doing.
Yeah.
So how has it for you,
you said you'd been there for six
months,
uh,
being uh,
an outsider in a pretty homogeneous
society.
Have you had any challenges on that
front?
Um,
I actually have nights.
It's pretty interesting like people
stare at you,
but people stare at anyone who isn't
japanese here.
It's,
I think 99 point seven percent of the
people here at japanese.
And the points three people who are left
are mostly korean and chinese.
But you're an oddity no matter what you
look like if you're from the west.
Do you speak japanese?
I speak japanese.
Aired quote gary,
don't worry.
I'm not going to test you.
Don't worry.
I started studying in college,
so I am in no way fluid.
Yeah,
that's nice.
Speak enough to prize people greatly.
Yeah.
So one of the things that you had
written in that you wanted to talk about
that I thought was really interesting
was about content creators being
unfairly criticized.
Um,
and I think what you were referring to
is generally just sort of these
youtubers that put their thoughts out
there that ended up getting trolled
endlessly.
That's the sense that I got.
Am I,
am I right on that?
And if not,
please correct me.
Yeah,
there's that.
And then there's the broader sense of
content creation where it's like there
are people who are writing books or
making comics or movies that are being
endlessly criticized with a very
ideological bents at this point to the
point where not meeting certain very
leftist standards is considered a
drawback in a fault when it probably
shouldn't inherently be.
Yeah.
So give me,
give me an example of that.
so it's like,
it's not like I am mad when women show
up in comic books,
but I don't think it's all that fair
when you get comic books polled because
they don't have women in them,
but that's not a drawback.
Yeah.
So that is the kind of see many years
ago now,
because I'm old with the joker comic
book cover where the joker was abusing
bat girl because the joker,
the joker,
but they had that comment but cover
poles and the artists essentially
blacklisted because they said it
encouraged violence against women and
that should not have happened.
The joker was a bad guy.
That's what bad guys do.
Yeah.
A lot of people seem to really mix up
what characters do versus what the
author dies.
So it's the George Lucas argument where
it's just like he put layer in a skimpy
outfits like jabba the hutt,
but later in a skimpy outfit,
his job in a hives is a bad guy and
you're supposed to think he's creepy.
Yeah.
Do you find that fascinating?
Yeah,
I mean I,
I find that totally fascinating that
people seem incapable of certain amount
of people are incapable of separating
the artists,
the creator,
George Lucas,
who draws,
you know,
comes up with the idea of java and then
he had it,
he had a slave and he put her in a sexy
outfit and people think that's him
imposing his view on what he thinks
women should be.
It's kinda crazy.
Yeah,
it's pretty ridiculous.
I don't wAnt to send George Lucas.
He's done verY objectionable things on
other things.
Jar jar is that a jar jar knock.
It's a knock against many,
many aspects of the star wars universe,
but not the slightly a thing.
It is fine.
Yeah.
You know that star wars is like
everything to me.
I mean,
I don't know what to say right now.
I'm sure you would agree with me on many
of my complaints.